Die Rasenfunk-Schlusskonferenz. Alles zum letzten Bundesligaspieltag.
Das ist doch schön, dass ich mit meiner Jingle-Auswahl, mit der Intro-Auswahl den lieben Frank gleich zum Lachen gebracht hab. Ich hab einen Klassiker der Rasenfunk-Geschichte rausgeholt, Wolf Fuss, der uns nicht kennt. Hallo Frank, schön, dass du hier bist.
Man weiß es nicht.
Man weiß es nicht. Also ich hatte Kontakt mit ihm, vielleicht aber nicht den allererfreulichsten, deswegen lassen wir das an dieser Stelle aus, die Geschichte. Du erinnerst dich ja wahrscheinlich.
Lass uns auch an dieser Stelle über erfreulichere Dinge sprechen.
Genau, genau. Du bist hier. Warum bist du denn hier, Frank? Das ist ja, Moment mal, da ist das überhaupt erlaubt?
Ja, tatsächlich. Wenn es um besondere Dinge geht oder darum, die Fragen der Hörerinnen und Supporterinnen zu beantworten, dann schaue ich immer mal kurz vorbei.
Genau, also heute, das ist eine Pflichtsendung, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ich sage es jetzt gleich, schaltet nicht ab. Mindestens eine Information aus dieser Sendung, die wir jetzt auch gleich am Anfang besprechen werden, ist extrem wichtig für euch, denn wir haben ein neues Konto, denn wir sind jetzt eine GmbH. Wie, warum, weshalb, das machen wir alles gleich. Erst mal herzlich willkommen in Rasenfunk Schlusskonferenz Nummer 392. Ich bin der Max, den Frank habt ihr gerade schon gehört. Wir zwei machen den Rasenfunk und auch in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei einigen Gästen, beziehungsweise wir wollen uns ja bedanken. Jetzt kann ich endlich mal im Wir sprechen. Frank ist ja mit hier und zwar in dieser Folge bei Christian, Thomas, Marc, André, Alexander, Maria und Joris. Diese fünf Menschen stehen stellvertretend für eine große Gruppe, die Frank und mir fast ein schlechtes Gewissen gemacht haben, denn sie haben uns einen, also die jetzt genannten, auch wirklich einen sehr generösen Betrag überwiesen für unseren WM-Boykott. Und das führt dazu, dass wir jetzt in dieser komischen Situation sind, dass wir durch den Boykott, also wir hatten keine Einbußen, das was wir befürchtet haben ist nicht eingetreten. Im Gegenteil, wir haben sogar ein bisschen Geld verdient wahrscheinlich, was wir natürlich weitergeben an Gäste und so weiter. Aber das fühlt sich etwas komisch an und ich wollte aber deswegen an dieser Stelle euch herausgepickt nochmal danken. Bei euch war es am einfachsten, die Namen zu finden. Ein paar andere haben auch noch überwiesen. Ich konnte jetzt nicht jeden Verwendungszweck checken. Aber ja, vielen herzlichen Dank und ich glaube, Frank, ich spreche für uns beides, hat uns überrascht, dass es dieses Echo gab.
Und an der Stelle vielleicht auch noch mal der Hinweis, wenn ihr in den Sendungen genannt werden wollt, denkt daran, nicht nur euren Support zu leisten, wofür wir natürlich sehr dankbar sind und was im Zweifel auch genug ist. Aber wenn ihr genannt werden wollt, geht auf rasenfunk.de, registriert euch dort als Supporter. Dann könnt ihr auch angeben, wie wir euch in der Sendung erwähnen. Mit dem Vornamen, mit dem Spitznamen, wie auch immer.
Exakt. Und ich habe jetzt hier quasi mit der Regel gebrochen, dass ich jetzt jemanden einfach so erwähnt habe. Aber ich hoffe, die Vornamen waren in Ordnung. Frank, wollen wir gleich das erste Thema tacklen? Denn das ist für uns beide auch extrem wichtig. Und es ist für uns auch sehr wichtig, dass ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, darüber Bescheid wisst, wir haben eine neue Konto-Verbindung. Und die alte, die soll eigentlich im Bestfall gar nicht mehr verwendet werden.
Vielleicht auch ein Stück weit zurecht, dass wir da natürlich jetzt alles sehr knapp gestaltet haben. Das hat verschiedene Gründe. Manches ging nicht so wirklich besser. Ein Stück weit ist aber auch einfach der Tatsache geschuldet, dass wir das jetzt zum neuen Jahr hinbekommen wollten. Und drum ist es jetzt ein bisschen kurzfristig bekommen, dass wir neues Konto haben und am besten der Wechsel sofort stattfinden sollte. Das hat verschiedene Gründe, aber vor allem eben buchhalterische. Die deutsche Bürokratie will da ihre Ordnung haben. Und es war auch leider nicht möglich, das alte Konto so einfach in die GmbH zu übernehmen. Max hat es ja erwähnt, wir haben eine GmbH gegründet. Da reden wir auch gleich noch drüber. Aber wichtig wäre tatsächlich für alle Supporter, dass ihr auf das neue Konto switcht. Ihr findet die Daten, wenn ihr als Supporter registriert wart, haben wir euch ohnehin schon eine E-Mail geschickt. Ansonsten findet ihr die neuen Kontodaten auf der Website.
Genau und natürlich hier in den Show Notes. Also das sollte nicht das Problem sein, die neuen Kontodaten zu finden. Und wir sind auch bei einer neuen Bank. Das heißt, man kann sehr einfach sehen, bin ich noch auf dem alten Konto oder bin ich auf dem neuen Konto. Wenn ihr zur Fidor Bank, die eine Swift oder eine Big hat, Entschuldigung, die mit FFD beginnt, dann seid ihr noch auf dem alten, dem falschen Konto. Und alles andere ist dann das Neue. Und ich glaube ehrlicherweise dieses ruckartige Wechseln, es wäre nicht anders gegangen, weil das Problem ist, also das Einzige, was wir hätten machen können, wäre schon Wochen vorher zu sagen, unsere Kontoverbindung wird sich ändern. Aber das haben wir aus dem Grund nicht gemacht, dass wir nicht genau sagen konnten, wann sie sich ändert. Und irgendwann wären die Nachfragen gekommen, hat sie sich denn jetzt schon geändert? Ich habe das vor drei Wochen gesagt, aber wir wissen es nicht. Deshalb habe ich immer gesagt, bitte registriert euch als Supporterinnen und Supporter. Wir haben eine wichtige Änderung und über die möchten wir euch dann informieren. Und wir haben es nicht anders gesagt. Und dann ist es tatsächlich so, jeder, der vielleicht schon mal etwas gegründet hat, der weiß das ja, wir haben das jetzt auch quasi am eigenen Leib noch mal alles durchgespielt. Eine GmbH gibt es, wenn man zum Notar läuft, dann erst kann man ein Konto beantragen, dann muss auf dieses Konto noch was eingezahlt werden, dann ist man eine GmbH in Gründung. Also sind wir quasi seit dem Notartermin. Dann gibt es auch erst diese Konto-Verbindung. Aber da gibt es quasi mehrere zeitliche Faktoren, auf die wir keinen Einfluss haben. Also wie lange dauert es, dass die Bank uns das Konto einrichtet, weil die müssen dann ein paar Dinge vom, naja, Identifizätsnachweise und so weiter und so weiter. Und ihr wisst ja, wie lang so was manchmal dauern kann. Und wie läuft das dann alles im weiteren Verlauf? Deswegen, ich glaube, anders als so wäre es auch nicht gegangen, wenn wir das jetzt im Juli, Juli oder so gemacht hätten.
Ja, was ich ganz interessant fand, Max, am ersten Feedback der SupporterInnen bezüglich des neuen Kontos war, dass öfter die Frage aufkam, ob es denn jetzt sinnvoll ist, auf weniger Überweisungen, also sprich einen großen Jahresbetrag, statt monatlich einen kleineren Betrag umzustellen. Da gibt es offenbar eine Sensibilität für Bankgebühren unter unseren HörerInnen. Und tatsächlich ist es aber bei uns jetzt in dem Fall so, dass es egal ist. Wir haben eine Bank gefunden, die gegen einen höheren monatlichen Pauschalbetrag keine Gebühren für die einzelnen Buchungen nimmt. Das heißt dahingehend ist es egal. Insgesamt ist es uns natürlich recht, wenn ihr euren Beitrag aufstocken könnt und uns mehr überweisen könnt. Aber es ist uns völlig egal, ob ihr monatlich einen kleineren Betrag oder jährlich einen größeren überweist.
Absolut und wir sind jetzt eben bei der Phenom Bank gelandet. Die hat eine BEC, eine BIC, die mit SOBKD beginnt, weil sie auch mit der Solaris Bank zusammenarbeitet. Das ist so eine dieser neueren Banken. Aber auch das war ein großes Thema, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das finden eine Bank, die halbwegs akzeptable Konditionen für jemanden hat, der sehr, sehr viele Kleinstüberweisungen bekommt. Ansonsten hätte es nämlich sein können, dass wir das euch kommuniziert hätten. Bitte stellt um von dem Betrag, den ihr jetzt monatlich macht, auf einen Jahresbetrag. Aber das brauchen wir zum Glück nicht. Das kann alles genauso weitergehen. Aber Frank, jetzt sollten wir, glaube ich, auch mal sagen, warum wir eigentlich eine GmbH gegründet haben. Soll ich mal loslegen und du ergänzt? Weil es sind ja eine Reihe von Gründen. Und der erste, und deswegen vielleicht ist es auch sinnvoll, dass ich loslege, ist noch mal kurz zu erklären, was war denn der Rasenfunk bisher? Der Rasenfunk war schon ein Gewerbe, ein Einzelunternehmen, das auf mich angemeldet war. Das hatte ein paar Vorteile, aber es hatte auch ein paar Nachteile. Unter anderem der, dass ich rein theoretisch jederzeit all das Konto hätte leerräumen können und auf die Bahamas gehen können. Und du hättest nichts dagegen tun können. Habe ich jetzt nicht gemacht, hatte ich auch nie vor. Aber das wäre immer möglich gewesen. Und aber tatsächlich auch, ich bin dann als Privatmensch haftend für alle Dinge, die den Rasenfunk betreffen. Und jetzt ist es zwar nicht so, dass wir erwarten, häufig verklagt zu werden, aber ausschließen kann man es nie. Und wenn man dann zum Beispiel auch so eine Sendung, wie jetzt zum Beispiel zu häuslichen Gewalt im Profifußball macht, und das soll definitiv nicht die letzte Folge dieser Art gewesen sein, dann bekommt das schon nochmal eine andere Relevanz, ob man da mit seinem Privatvermögen haftet oder eben mit einer beschränkten Haftung. Also eine MBH, das ist ja das MBH in GmbH. Also das war einer der Gründe. Und auch, und dann darfst du gerne mal den Staffelstab übernehmen, dass wir auch im Einzelunternehmen Rasenfunk, das, wie wir den Rasenfunk machen, nicht so gut abbilden konnten. Also es ist ja so, wir entscheiden alle Dinge gemeinsam. Also hier ist quasi, wie hat es unser Steuerberater gesagt? Der Notar 50 plus 9, nee, wir haben über 50 plus 1 geredet. Und die 1 ist aber quasi die andere Person. Also wir haben 50 plus 50. Es geht nur, wenn wir beide uns einig sind. Gleichzeitig ist es aber so, dass wir bei der finanziellen Beteiligung am Rasenfunkgewinn dann schon mit einfliegen lassen, dass ich ja etwas mehr Arbeit habe als du in der Regel usw. Das hatten wir zwar abgebildet im Einzelunternehmen, aber das war alles immer erklärungsbedürftig. Und da haben sämtliche beteiligt, die haben nachgefragt, die Steuerberaterin, das Finanzamt. Wir haben eine Steuerprüfung bekommen. Kurz gesagt kann man vielleicht auch zusammenfassen, so wie wir unser Geld verdienen, das ist dem deutschen Staat suspekt. Das kann doch nicht mit rechten Dingen zugehen, dass Leute freiwillig für etwas weinen. Da sind wir jetzt durch sehr viele Mühlen durchgegangen, monatelang und auch das sollte jetzt hoffentlich mit der GmbH einfacher werden. Das sind jetzt mal ein paar Gründe und ein paar mehr haben wir ja noch.
Ja, ich glaube, du hast eigentlich das Wichtigste schon gesagt, was für mich auch ein wichtiger Punkt ist, ist das Auftreten des Rasenfunks nach außen hin. Als GmbH signalisiert man einfach jedem, dass es uns hier ernst ist und dass das eine längerfristige, dauerhafte Geschichte ist. Dass es nicht unbedingt, eine GmbH gründet man nicht, um mal eben einen Podcast zu starten, von dem man nicht weiß, ob er in einem Jahr noch existiert. Ich glaube, das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Dann eben, wie Max schon sagte, es ist unser beider Ding. Das war es auch immer, jetzt seit mittlerweile acht Jahren, über acht Jahren. Aber in der GmbH wird das einfach noch mal als festgeschriebenes Faktum dokumentiert. Das war uns eben wichtig, das so zu haben.
Genau, gleichzeitig ist damit auch etwas erledigt, vor dem ich mich immer ein bisschen rumgedrückt habe. Jetzt wäre auch festgelegt, was wäre denn, wenn einem von uns beiden etwas passiert? Oder wenn einer von uns beiden ist überhaupt nicht absehbar? Also entspannt euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Aber wenn einer von uns beiden aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht mehr bei dem Projekt mitmachen wollte und so weiter, ist jetzt alles einfacher geworden, dadurch, dass dieses Ding nicht mehr einfach auf meinen Namen läuft und auch die Konten laufen nicht mehr auf meinen Namen. Das ist mir ehrlicherweise auch viel lieber, weil ich fand das immer komisch, dass man Namen gegeben hat, dass man mir das Geld überweist. Also offenbar war es ja für die Hörerinnen und Hörer kein Problem. Aber ich finde es schöner, dass man jetzt nämlich dann als Empfänger die Rasenfunk GmbH hat und nicht mehr Max Jakob Ost. Das gefällt mir viel besser, ehrlicherweise. Dazu muss man ja auch sagen, für uns ist es auch so ein nächster Schritt. Also ein bisschen das, was du jetzt gerade gesagt hast, ist in der Außendarstellung. Und das signalisiert ja auch schon, der Rasenfunk hat sich gewandelt. Wir haben jetzt nicht vor, zu verschwinden so schnell. Ich sehe es ehrlicherweise so als eine Treppe. Und das ist jetzt quasi die erste Stufe der GmbH, die es uns leichter macht, nächste Stufen zu nehmen. Also mit einer GmbH ändert sich auch zum Beispiel, wie wir bezahlt werden. Also wir beide werden dann ein Gehalt bekommen von der GmbH. Wir werden dann eine Lohnbuchhaltung haben. Es wird alles noch ganz spannend. Ich freue mich nur so mittel.
Das sind die wenige, die schön was meckten.
Ich hatte mich gerade an den ganzen anderen Kram gewöhnt.
Die Produkazie wird nicht weniger leider.
Ja, da wird leider natürlich dann auch ein bisschen von eurem Geld drin. Verschwinden lieber Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das ist leider so. Aber wir müssen eben auch, und wir wollen ja auch alles sehr, sehr sauber und ordentlich machen. Deswegen holen wir uns da immer Profis. Also wir hatten schon immer eine Steuerberaterin. Und die wird jetzt aber vermutlich noch ein bisschen mehr involviert, an manchen Stellen zumindest. Aber wenn wir eben einen Gehalt bekommen, dann gäbe es zumindest auch die Möglichkeit, wenn sich eure Spenden so entwickeln, dass zum Beispiel auch jemand anderes mal einen Gehalt bekäme. Also es wäre jetzt viel einfacher als im Einzelunternehmen, wo es zwar möglich gewesen wäre, aber eben ein bisschen komplizierter, dann auch jemanden fester in den Rasenfunk reinzuholen. Vielleicht auch regelmäßiger in den Rasenfunk reinzuholen. Das wäre durchaus so eine Entwicklungsstufe. Also ich hab da schon wieder ganz verrückte Gedanken. Eins hab ich dir noch gar nicht erzählt, Frank. Müssen wir im Off-Gespräch dann machen. Aber über die WM, das hab ich dir ja schon beim Notartermin erzählt, dass ich am liebsten, naja, anderes Thema, weiß nicht, um was du mich besprechen sollten. Aber das wird alles einfacher. Und da freu ich mich auch richtig drauf, dass wir mit der GmbH da auch einfach noch mal andere Möglichkeiten haben.
Ja, definitiv. Und gerade eben das Integrieren von weiteren Personen wird ja auch jedem einleuchten, der jetzt auch feststellt, wie deine Last mit zum Beispiel den neuen Sendungen zum Thema Frauenfußball weiter gestiegen ist. Und da haben ja auch schon viele gefragt, Mensch, wie sieht es denn da jetzt eigentlich aus? Wie klappt denn das alles zeitlich noch? Insofern ist auch klar, dass unser Gedanke langfristig in Richtung Ausweitung geht und da ist die GmbH jetzt einfach die solide Basis, dafür die nötige.
Genau und ansonsten hat sich aber im Grunde nichts geändert. Wir beide sind weiter diejenigen, die den Rasenfunk machen und bestimmen, wie hier der Hase läuft. Und eure Spenden fließen jetzt auch nicht in neue Geschäftsräume, in denen wir uns irgendwie, was war das für ein tolles Parkett, was sich die RBB-Chefin verlegen hat, lassen. Naja, also das machen wir jetzt nicht, sondern ansonsten ändert sich gar nichts. Und es wird weiter so sein, dass eben ein großer Teil eurer Spenden, Frank und mir, zugute kommt und aber ein wachsender Teil der Spenden, auch den Gästen, die wir im Rasenfunk haben. Dazu habe ich auch die Zahlen mal rausgesucht. Die Supporterinnen und Supporter kennen sie schon aus der E-Mail, die wir ihnen geschickt haben. Also im Jahr 2021 hatten wir damals rund 8000 Euro an Gästehonoraren überwiesen. Im Jahr 2022 haben wir tatsächlich, toll, jetzt habe ich das Fenster so klein gemacht, dass ich hier scrollen muss, aber ich möchte nichts falsches sagen, 13.500 Euro an Honoraren erzielt. Also ihr seht, da haben wir uns schon deutlich gesteigert.
Beachtliches Wachstum, ne?
Absolut und das ist ja auch das Ziel. Also meine Hoffnung ist immer, dass die Spenden sich so entwickeln, dass wir zwei uns immer ein Gehalt zahlen können. Also jetzt ist es ja ein Gehalt, mit dem wir auskommen. Vielleicht muss da dann irgendwann noch mal so ein Energiebonus mit drauf. Mal gucken, wenn die Abrechnungen kommen. Aber eigentlich war es ja jetzt die letzte Zeit, ich würde sagen das ganze Jahr 2022 war es doch so, Frank, du musst mich korrigieren, wenn ich da irgendwas vergessen habe, das, was mehr reinkam, ging an die Gäste raus. Jetzt nicht, dass irgendwie mehr hängen geblieben ist. Hat sich lustigerweise so ein bisschen ergeben, weil wir einmal die Honorare angepasst haben, etwas erhöht hatten und ich dann eben auch viel mehr Sendungen gemacht habe. Also es war jetzt quasi, wir können jetzt nicht die Honorare so fluide irgendwie für jede Sendung anders machen. Das wäre auch ein bisschen ungerecht den Gästen gegenüber. Aber finde ich eigentlich sehr schön, dass wir jetzt schon bei 13.500 Euro stehen. Und ich sag mal, 2023 muss die, na wobei, will ich die 20.000 aufrufen? Ich ruf die 20.000 auf. Komm, Leute, 2023 muss die 20.000 fallen. Ja, genau. Also, um diesen Blog kurz zusammenzufassen, bitte ändert eure Überweisung an uns. Also bitte macht das auf die neue E-Bahn. Die beginnt mit DE 41 und hört mit einer 5.0 auf. Die ganze findet ihr in den Show Notes und auch auf rasenfunk.de und überall auf unseren Social Media Plattformen. Ihr müsst dabei auch daran denken, den Empfänger bitte auf Rasenfunk zu ändern, dass es nicht mehr an Max Jakob ausgeht. Aber auch das steht alles in den Informationen. Macht das bitte schnell, denn wir können zukünftige Gästehonorare nur vom GmbH-Konto bezahlen. Wir können das nicht mehr vom alten Konto machen. Und es ist auch nicht so einfach möglich, da Geld hin und her zu schieben. Das wird tatsächlich ein bisschen schwieriger, wenn man eine GmbH hat und wenn man ein bisschen drüber nachdenkt, dann hat das ja auch durchaus auch seinen Sinn, dass dem so ist. Ansonsten ändert sich aber erst mal nichts. Wir sind jetzt aufgestellt, dafür den Rasenfunk weiter zu professionalisieren und vielleicht ein paar Entwicklungsstufen zu nehmen, die sonst einfach viel, viel schwieriger zu nehmen wären. Für euch ändert sich aber ansonsten eigentlich gar nichts. Das Geld kommt weiter demselben Zweck zugute. Und da hängt jetzt nicht Martin Kind mit drin und kriegt irgendwie 49% davon. Keine Sorge.
Genau, das wollte ich gerade auch nochmal sagen, weil ich glaube, das ist bisher gar nicht gefallen. Max und ich, das hat Max, glaube ich, erwähnt. Wir sind gleichberechtigte Gesellschafter eben, aber auch die einzigen Gesellschafter in der GmbH. Das heißt, das ist weiterhin rein unser Ding. Und noch ein Punkt zu der Konto-Geschichte und zu den Überweisungen. Wir müssen leider damit rechnen, dass wir nicht alle, die uns bisher auf dem alten Konto unterstützt haben, mit auf das neue Konto sozusagen umziehen können. Wir werden da höchstwahrscheinlich einen gewissen Anteil verlieren. Das heißt, wenn das für euch ein Grund ist oder wenn ihr die Möglichkeit habt, zu sagen, Mensch, da packe ich einen Euro oder zwei drauf bei meiner monatlichen Überweisung, würden wir uns sehr darüber freuen. Dann können wir vielleicht diesen Verlust ein bisschen kompensieren. Wir wissen natürlich noch nicht genau, wie groß er denn ist.
Ja, genau, stimmt. Und das ist noch etwas, das ist noch wichtig, dazu zu sagen, vielleicht haben es einige von euch schon bemerkt, wir haben damit begonnen, zumindest in manchen Supporterinnen und Supportern, wahrscheinlich werden wir es nicht bei allen schaffen, aber eine 1-Cent-Überweisung auf ihr Konto zu buchen, in dem im Verwendungszweck nochmal steht, Achtung bitte, Konto ändern, alle Informationen unter rasenfunk.de Das kommt von uns, das seht ihr ja, es kommt ja vom Rasenfunk Konto, also da ist Missbrauch, denke ich, ausgeschlossen. Manche von euch haben diese Überweisung schon bekommen, manche werden sie noch bekommen, wahrscheinlich wird sie aber nicht jeder von euch bekommen haben am Ende, denn das ist eine reine Kapazitätenfrage, wenn man für jede einzelne Überweisung eine Ämterin sich aufs Handy schicken lassen muss. Habt ihr schon ein paar hundert Überweisungen schon gemacht, weil wir auch auf diesem Wege glauben, dass wir diesen eingesetzten einen Cent pro Supporterin und Supporter, der ist es wahrscheinlich wert, wenn wir damit einfach noch ein paar darauf aufmerksam machen, die es nicht mitbekommen haben. Also wundert euch nicht. Das kommt von uns. Das hat alles seine Richtigkeit. Das ist einfach nur unser, unser etwas verzweifelter Versuch, euch auch auf diesen Weg zu erreichen. Denn es gibt eben manche Leute, die uns auch schon lange unterstützen und die vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr die Folgen hören und vielleicht auch den Newsletter nicht abonniert haben und auch in den sozialen Netzwerken nicht aktiv sind. Also wundert euch nicht, das kommt noch. Und den Send, den könnt ihr so richtig in unserem Namen auf den Kopf hauen, würde ich sagen.
Max, wollen wir vielleicht mal zu den Q&A übergehen?
Ja, aber unbedingt.
Zu den Fragen der Hörerinnen und Hörer. Genau, wir haben euch im Forum unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de gefragt oder beziehungsweise angeregt, uns Fragen zu stellen für die Sendung. Und da ist natürlich wieder jede Menge zusammengekommen. Diesmal gab es ein paar Diskussionen quer im Thread. Daher ist es nicht ganz so einfach. Ich mache das wie immer oder wir haben das wie immer gemacht. Max hat sich den Thread vorher nicht angeguckt. Und ich werde jetzt während wir die Sendung aufzeichnen, einfach mal durchgehen und eure Fragen rauspecken. Bitte vorab schon mal um Entschuldigung, wenn mir da die ein oder andere entgeht, beziehungsweise auch um Verzeihung, dass ich den einen oder anderen Beitrag absichtlich überspringe, wenn es weniger eine Frage ist als vielleicht nur eine Anmerkung. Die sind dann teilweise auch recht lang. Das würde jetzt den Rahmen der Sendung springen. Fangen wir an mit dem lieben Vollspann. Der fragt, wird der Rasenfunk auf Mastodon aktiv? Falls ja, wann? Man sieht, der Thread ist schon eine Weile auf, denn wir sind schon auf Mastodon aktiv. Und zwar seit einer Woche ungefähr, Max, oder?
Ja, eigentlich eine Frage, die dann doch mehr an dich ging, denn das Thema Mastodon lag bei dir. Wir haben da verschiedene Optionen geprüft. Wir sind jetzt auf Mastodon, und zwar auf der Instanz Podcasts.Social. Da findet ihr uns. Mir fällt auch gerade siedenteils ein, dass ich das ja auch unbedingt, also auf der Webseite müssen wir das vielleicht mal unterbringen. Da ist es noch nicht drauf. Der Frank hat seine Hausaufgaben gemacht, dann hab ich meine Hausaufgaben noch zu machen. Ich muss es dann noch in die Vorlagen für die Show-Notes mit reinnehmen. Da steht unten dran. Aber wir sind jetzt auf Masterdome. Podcasts.social ist unsere Instanz. Und wenn ihr auch dort seid, könnt ihr uns gerne folgen.
Und addrasenfunk ist natürlich der Notzeig. Genau, addrasenfunk, addpodcasts.social quasi oder podcasts.social slash addrasenfunk, wenn ihr es im Browser aufrufen wollt. War längst überfällig, genau, wie Max schon sagte. Da waren ein paar Optionen da. Und jetzt haben wir uns für diesen Weg entschieden. Ich glaube, das ist eine ganz gute Sache. Da haben die Jungs vom Sendegate tatsächlich auch was Schönes aufgezogen mit podcast.social als quasi Anlaufstation auch wirklich nur für Podcast-Accounts. Das heißt, das ist auch gar nicht für einzelne beteiligte Personen gedacht, sondern wirklich nur für die Podcasts selber. Das ist eine feine Sache.
Aber absolut. Seit wann bist du bei Mastaton, Frank?
Im Moment steht in meinem Profil seit November 22, weil ich auf einen eigenen Server gezogen bin. Aber davor war ich bei Mastaton Social seit 2016, glaube ich.
Guck mal an, ich wusste es, dass du wieder vor mir dran warst. Ich bin seit 2018 bei Mastaton. Wir haben uns damals kollektiv über irgendwas aufgeregt. Vielleicht war es Donald Trump oder irgendwie so.
Es gab mehrere Wellen dahingehend, ja. Wobei die diesmal zu halten scheint. Ich glaube, diesmal wird eine gewisse Menge auf Mastaton bleiben. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass einige schon aus meiner Bubble fest bei Mastaton sind mittlerweile.
Geht mir auch so. Ich verwende es jetzt auch tatsächlich als eigenständige App. Ich habe das Cross-Posten sehr früh gelassen, weil mich das bei anderen Leuten immer nervt. Da dachte ich, dann darf man selber auch nicht machen. Und ich bin noch nicht so aktiv, weil ich aber auch ehrlicherweise gerade nicht so den krassen Output habe. Also bei Twitter habe ich so meine laufenden Projekte mit irgendwie der Kopftreffer-Thread muss noch aktualisiert werden und so weiter. Aber ich lese da schon sehr gerne mit. Und es ist auch schön zu sehen, dass der Rasenfunk da auch schon ein paar Follower hat.
Kubix, C-U-B-I-K-S, Kubix, ein neuer User im Forum sagt, hallo Genetzer, in den Schlusskonferenzen erwähnst du manchmal, dass du alle Bundesligaspiele eines Vereins über 90 Minuten gesehen hast. Wie machst du das bei englischen Wochen und bei Schlusskonferenzen, die du nicht selber moderierst und aus gutem Grund nicht dabei bist, guckst du dann im Nachgang noch einmal alle Spiele, um wirklich alle Spiele gesehen zu haben?
Also, englische Wochen sind tough und bei englischen Wochen, glaube ich, war es meistens so, dass ich, also manchmal habe ich es geschafft, alle 9 Spiele zu gucken, das ging aber so sehr zu Lasten meines Schlafkontos. Und dann auch fand ich der Sendungsqualität, dass ich da, glaube ich, ich glaube, 8 Spiele schaffe ich es immer zu sehen oder sind es 7? Ich kann es jetzt gerade nicht genau sagen. Es hängt auch immer ein bisschen damit zusammen, wie da hier dann die Situation bei mir zu Hause gerade ist, mit Kindern und so weiter. Deswegen, also englische Wochen schaffe ich nicht alle zu sehen. Und wenn ich mal eine Folge nicht moderiere, ich glaube das, ja, also, ich fürchte, dass ich mich jetzt endgültig abstempel zum harten Nerd. Tatsächlich war es in dieser Saison so, dass ich die Spiele dann auf einem zweiten Bildschirm im Nachhinein unter der Woche dann noch mal alle gesehen habe, weil ich meinen Kopftreffer-Thread pflegen wollte. Und ich weiß aber nicht, ob ich das im Nachhinein so gut fand. Also ich habe es nicht gemacht, um sagen zu können, hey, ich habe alle Spiele gesehen, weil so wichtig ist es dann auch nicht, ob man dann 34 Spiele gesehen hat oder 30 Spiele von einem, von einem Team in einer Saison. Es war eher aus dem anderen Grund. Und ob ich das in Zukunft immer machen werde, weiß ich nicht. Es hängt halt krass an der Zeit.
Sweet Kiss schreibt, wie beurteilst du jetzt nach der WM deine Entscheidung des Boykots? Inwiefern hast du das sportliche und die mediale Rezeption des sportlichen und der politischen Aspekte wahrgenommen? Ein persönlicher Gedanke, der sich mir als Zuschauer aufgedrängt hat, ich habe den Rasenfunk vermisst. Die deutsche Fernsehberichterstattung an den ersten Tagen noch empört über Katar und die Kapitänsbinden-Thematik. Nach einer Woche war man dann aber auch fertig mit den Nebenshow-Plätzen. Ich bin mir sicher, dass der Rasenfunk das Programm deutlich interessanter gestaltet hätte. Das gilt auch sportlich, denn ARD und ZDF haben sich mit der Bewertung des Sportlichen auf einem peinlich niedrigen Niveau bewegt. Und ja, ich weiß, dass man auch eigenständige Recherchearbeit leisten kann und sich nicht von einem Podcatcher abhängig machen muss. Ja, das ist die Frage oder der Kommentar dazu, für den er auch vier Likes bekommen hat. Also das interessiert offenbar noch den ein oder anderen.
Also ich kann nichts sagen zur Berichterstattung. Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, Frank. Ich glaube, das haben wir noch kein Problem. Naja, siehst du ich nämlich auch nicht. Keine einzige Sekunde.
Doch, ne, stimmt gar nicht. Ich habe zehn Minuten vom ersten Spiel der Deutschen gesehen, glaube ich. Aber das war's.
Genau.
Und ich habe auch kaum was mitbekommen. Ich habe das deutsche Ausscheiden mitbekommen. Ich habe Marokko als Hoffnungsträger derer, die gerne Überraschungsmannschaften sehen. Mitbekommen, und dass es das Finale wohl ein gutes Spiel war. Und ich habe gar nicht bewusst boykottiert. Es ist gar nicht zu mir vorgedrungen so richtig.
Also bei mir ist auch so, ich habe keine einzige Sekunde gesehen, nichts vom Finale, also nichts von keinem Spiel. Deswegen kann ich 0,0 zur Berichterstattung sagen. Habe ich keine Ahnung, wie die war in anderen Medien. Interessanterweise weiß ich, aber glaube ich, alles, was ich zu dieser WM wissen muss. Weil ich zwar, ich habe gewisse Hashtags gemutet bei Twitter, aber ich folge natürlich so vielen Sportjournalistinnen und Journalisten, dass ich dann trotzdem sehr viel mitbekommen habe. Außerdem habe ich, das war quasi, ich weiß nicht, ob man das als Ausnahme von meinem WM-Bockrott nehmen darf, aber den Newsletter von Tobi Escher, der wie immer fantastisch war, den habe ich, da habe ich jede Ausgabe gelesen. Deswegen kann ich hier wahnsinnig viel auch taktisch erzählen zu dieser WM, ohne ein Spiel gesehen zu haben. Das ist total, total verrückt. Und bis aus Finale, wo ich jetzt überlege, ob man das vielleicht irgendwann noch mal sehen muss, weil man es gesehen haben muss als Sportjournalist, weil es ja dann doch etwas Besonderes war, da bin ich mir noch nicht einig. Und wenn, dann wird es erst in ein paar Monaten geschehen. Aber ansonsten reizt mich auch tatsächlich nichts. Und im Nachhinein bin ich aber sehr froh über den WM-Boykott, den wir gemacht haben. Beziehungsweise auch die Entscheidung, es nicht stattfinden zu lassen. Zum einen, weil ich ganz dringend diese Pause gebraucht habe. Was ich unter anderem daran gemerkt habe, dass ich eigentlich mehr als die Hälfte der Pause krank war und vor mich hingekränkt habe. Man hat es auch in den letzten beiden Sendungen gehört, im Kurzpass und in der letzten Schlusskonferenz. Da war ich noch ein bisschen angeschlagen. Und das ist ja dann doch auch ein Zeichen. Und zum anderen, weil alles eigentlich genauso gekommen ist, wie ich es mir ungefähr vorher ausgemalt habe. Und zwar so, dass am Anfang jedes Thema ein Riesen-Aufreger ist. Also jedes nicht-sportliche Thema auch ein Riesen-Aufreger ist. Die Diskussion dessen auch sehr mannigfaltig und laut ist. Und spätestens gegen Ende der Gruppenphase hört sowas aber immer auf. Dann rutschen immer die sportlichen Themen in den Vordergrund. Und ich möchte da der Nutzer oder der Nutzerin vorsichtig widersprechen. Ich glaube und befürchte, es wäre ähnlich auch im Rasenfunk gewesen. Denn gerade als ein Medium, das sich eben aufs Sportliche konzentriert, normalerweise und eben sehr analytisch und sachlich über Spiele spricht, wir hätten ganz sicher das deutsche Ausscheiden anders besprochen als andere. Und das heißt, auch bei uns wäre es so gewesen, dass es diesen Effekt gegeben hätte, den es ja auch schon 2018 gab und den ich eben im Nachhinein festgestellt habe und über den ich nicht glücklich war. Man lässt sich, zu Recht vielleicht auch, aber man lässt sich mitreißen von den Spielen. Denn die Dynamik eines Turniers, die ist immer toll. Es gibt Favoriten, die ausscheiden. Es gibt Überraschungssiege. Und dann gibt es eben die KO-Phase, wo jedes Spiel zählt, wo jede Schiedsrichterentscheidung zählt, jeder verschossene Strafstoß, Grüße Hurricane und so weiter und so fort. Und das wäre auch im Rasenfunk so gewesen, dass wir ab einem gewissen Punkt vor allem darüber geredet hätten. Und deswegen bin ich im Nachhinein froh, dass wir es nicht gemacht haben und glaube auch, dass man jetzt nicht so tun muss, als ob es irgendwie, wenn der Rasenfunkbericht erstattet hätte, dann hätten wir vielleicht manchmal eine andere Facette mit reingebracht. Aber im Großen und Ganzen glaube ich, wäre es dann doch ähnlich gewesen zu dem, wie es alle großen Medien gemacht haben. Denn das hat ja auch seinen Grund, dass die das so tun. Ist ja nicht so, dass irgendwie da eine versteckte Agenda hinter wäre, sondern so funktionieren halt solche Turniere. Am Schluss geht es immer nur noch darum, wer ist ins Finale gekommen und wie ist das gelaufen und so weiter.
Und das zeigt ja auch, warum es für Katar so wertvoll war, diese WM zu bekommen. Weil sie das natürlich auch wissen. Bei all der Kritik, die stattfindet und bei all der Diskussion darum, die sie vielleicht in manchen Phasen in der Härte nicht erwartet haben, wissen sie aber halt dann doch, dass am Ende in der breiten Masse vor allem viel Jubel um eine WM ist, um ein Finale, um einzelne Bilder daraus.
Definitiv. Es war ja auch viel positiver in anderen Ländern. Und kommerziell, obwohl das mit weitem Abstand die teuerste WM der bisherigen Geschichte war, war es auch die kommerzielle Erfolgreichste. Also die FIFA hat wahnsinnig viel Kohle geschaffelt. Gastarbeiter und Volunteers bekommen davon natürlich nichts. Ist klar, so viel Kohle haben sie dann doch nicht. Da müssen es dann doch nochmal 100 Milliarden mehr sein oder keine Ahnung, ab wann da dann losginge. Aber es war ein sehr, sehr erfolgreiches Turnier und wird auch das Abziehbild von kommenden Turnieren sein. Und auch dafür ist dann, finde ich, so ein Boykott da. Ich meine, hier in Deutschland wurde das ja sehr, sehr viel kritischer gesehen als im Grunde auf in weiten Teilen der Welt, der sonstigen Welt. Wahrscheinlich hängt das auch damit zusammen, dass man sich mit dem Team, das Deutschland vertritt, auch nicht so identifiziert in der groben Masse. Aber ich denke jetzt eigentlich schon darüber nach. Also zum einen jetzt auf uns kommt eine Frauen-WM zu in Australien und Neuseeland. Die wird von demselben Verband veranstaltet und auch von einem Verband, der gerade den Frauenfußball auf Kosten der Gesundheit der Spielerinnen auspresst, wie eine Zitrone. Das ist eigentlich ein Skandal, was gerade im Frauenfußball passiert. Alle Spielerinnen beklagen sich darüber, dass die Spiellast jetzt schon zu hoch ist. Wir haben schwere Verletzungen bei weltbekannten Spielerinnen, bei sehr guten Spielerinnen, die sich durch die Frauenfußball-Saison durchziehen und die eben noch gehäufter sind aufgrund mancher medizinischer Umstände, also Kreuzbandrisse, sind eben häufiger bei Frauen. Und die Reaktion der Verbände sowohl von UEFA als auch von FIFA auf dieses Klagen der Spielerinnen, die sagen, ey Leute, es ist zu viel, wir kriegen das alles nicht mehr hin, unsere Körper rebellieren, die Reaktion darauf ist, noch mehr Spiele, noch mehr Spiele, noch mehr Spiele, also absolut krass. Und ich denke schon viel drüber nach, wie wird das dann im Sommer sein? Weil da werden wir über die Frauen WM definitiv berichten. Was wird vielleicht mal so ein späterer Blick noch mal auf Qatar sein, der schon sehr gerne im Rasenfunk stattfinden darf? Also ich hätte große Lust darauf, mal in ein paar Monaten zum Beispiel noch mal eine Sendung zu machen und dann sehr genau auszuwählen, mit wem man darüber dann spricht. Und dann eben auch das kommende Turnier, also USA, Kanada, Mexiko allein unter logistischen Gesichtspunkten. Also Nachhaltigkeit auch hier nicht ganz so doll. Die Logistik für Fans, absolute Katastrophe, offener Schlag ins Gesicht. Auch hier nicht so, dass man sagen könnte, alle drei Länder sind Vorzeigeländer. Wird es übrigens auch nicht so sein bei der Europameisterschaft 2024. Da werden wir die harten Standards, die wir an Katar anlegen wollten, in großen Teilen. Da muss dann Deutschland erst mal zeigen, ob man da mitziehen kann, ob man da wirklich ein Turnier für alle machen kann. Ein inklusives Turnier, ein diverses Turnier. Also da bin ich mal sehr, sehr gespannt. Da müssen wir auch sehr kritisch hingucken. Aber ich denke ehrlich gesagt schon gar nicht mehr so sehr an die WM in Katar, sondern ausgehend von Katar denke ich mir, okay, das muss auch die Berichterstattung in den nächsten Jahren prägen. Was kann man da draus lernen?
Das war jetzt eine sehr ausführliche Beantwortung der Frage.
Ich mach nur selbst.
Alles gut, alles gut. Aber du hast gerade über die vielen Milliarden im Umfeld der Katar WM gesprochen. Daran schließt die nächste Frage an von Yuvi. Wie ist denn die finanzielle Situation beim Rasenfunk? Spüren wir die wirtschaftliche Situation, will er wissen?
Scheiße, ich hab's gerade nicht offen. Aber warte. Also der erste Teil jetzt aus dem Kopf und dann werde ich das kurz validieren. Wir haben ja einen Ort, an dem die Einnahmen zusammengefasst sind. Ich glaube, wir müssten ungefähr auf dem Vorjahr sein. Wir hatten so eins, eine kurze Anzeichen, wo man mal gemerkt hat, da hab ich es ja auch einmal oder zweimal in der Schlusskonferenz erwähnt, dass uns manche Leute die Unterstützung aufgrund der wirtschaftlichen Lage sehr wahrscheinlich gestrichen haben. Dann sind aber sofort Leute eingesprungen. Also schon diese Nebenerwähnungen haben eigentlich dazu geführt, dass wir uns, glaube ich, auf dem Niveau des Vorjahres bewegen. Ich glaube, das ist auch die Steuerberaterin neulich gesagt hat.
Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass auch unterm Strich das Motto oder die Zusammenfassung sein kann, die die negative Auswirkung ist, dass die Entwicklung stagniert ist. Das ist tatsächlich das Negativste, was uns passiert ist, Gott sei Dank. Aber man kann schon sagen, dass das Wachstum, das wir in den letzten Jahren immer hatten, ist erst mal stagniert, was völlig okay ist. Aber was wir natürlich trotzdem im Blick haben müssen, wir haben ja gerade über die GmbH gesprochen und über die Dinge, die wir in Zukunft vorhaben, wofür natürlich ein gewisses Wachstum nötig ist.
Ja, ich habe es jetzt gerade noch mal nachgeguckt, es ist wirklich fast gleichbleibend mit dem Vorjahr und eben dann eine Stagnation, die man eben sehr positiv deuten sollte. Gleichzeitig sträubt sich alles in mir, wenn ich mir denke, Mensch, der kapitalistische Wachstumsgedanke, jetzt ist er auch im Rasenfunk angekommen. Wobei es ja kein Wachstum zum Bedienen von irgendwelchen Krediten und zum Abbezahlen von irgendwelchen Maschinen ist, sondern ein inhaltliches Wachstum, aber trotzdem lustig, dass wir jetzt auch, mein Gott Frank, wir können es nicht, wir sind jetzt Gesellschafter, Frank, wir sind jetzt Wachstumsarschlöcher. Aber läuft alles gut und wir sind sehr dankbar darum. Gleichzeitig aber auf dem, ziemlich exakt sogar, auf dem Vorjahresniveau, das heißt quasi für weitere Schritte des Rasenfunks, müsste dann tatsächlich etwas noch mal passieren. Aber vielleicht tut es das ja auch.
Genau. Die Rita hat zwei Punkte angesprochen. Zum einen sagt sie, mich würden die Hörerinnen zahlen, was die Berichterstattung über den Frauenfußball angeht, interessieren. Und sie ist inzwischen unglaublich neugierig, was für eine Neuerung es im Rasenfunk geben wird, weil Max es so oft angekündigt hat. Rita, da muss ich dich ein klein bisschen enttäuschen, die GmbH war schon die Neuerung.
Ich hab's oversold, sagt man dann gleich dazu.
Genau, wahrscheinlich ein bisschen. Also dahingehend keine ganz große spannende Neuerung im Moment, was natürlich nicht heißt, dass es im nächsten Jahr noch tolle Neuerungen geben wird. Da kann man jetzt noch nicht so viel mehr drüber sagen. Aber zu den Hörer in Zahlen beim Frauenfußball, Max, wir haben da ja keine wirklich dedizierten Zahlen, aber vielleicht so eine Wahrnehmung.
Ja, ich bin gerade dabei, es rauszusuchen, hab mich gerade verklickt, deswegen muss ich hier noch kurz Zeit überbrücken, während sich Podergy die neuen Zahlen holt.
Man muss dann natürlich dazu sagen, vielleicht kann ich da auch noch kurz einspringen. Wir haben uns ja, da werden wir auch gleich in dieser Sendung noch was zusagen. Wir haben uns im Sommer ja dazu entschieden, den Frauenfußball, oder Max hat das angeregt, und wir haben das dann jetzt so umgesetzt, den Frauenfußball mehr Raum zu geben, mehr darüber zu sprechen, mehr Sendung zu haben. Und auch aber bewusst dafür, das nicht in einem eigenen Feed zu tun. Das heißt, die Zahlen sind jetzt so ein bisschen relativ, weil das taucht natürlich im bisherigen Kurzpass- und Schlusskonferenzfeed mit auf. Das heißt, die Downloads passieren teilweise unabhängig davon, ob jemand die Sendung dann hört oder nicht hört. Oder insofern sind die Zahlen natürlich ein bisschen relativ. Aber ich glaube, allein am Feedback kann man sagen, dass das ganz gut angenommen wird.
Absolut, also das ist definitiv so. Alles, was du sagst, ist richtig. Die Zahlen sind, da sind eben noch Downloads mit dabei von Leuten, die dann die Folge gar nicht gehört haben. Sind es aber ehrlicherweise wahrscheinlich bei den anderen Folgen auch. Da wird es nur nicht so häufig thematisiert, was ja auch schon mal ein interessanter Befund ist. Also ich habe jetzt die Zahlen hier für die Schlusskonferenzen, kann ich sagen. Also da hatten wir ja die Saisonvorschau und jetzt die Hinrundenbilanz. Die liegen ungefähr bei einer halben Männerschlusskonferenz. Also bei Männerschlusskonferenzen sind wir so bei 30.000 so Pi mal Daumen. Und da sind wir jetzt über 15.000. Also zwar ein bisschen deutlich über 15.000, aber sagen wir einfach mal so grob die Hälfte. Und ich würde auch vermuten, dass davon dann alle gehört haben, weil der Unterschied schon so deutlich ist, dass oder sehr viele wahrscheinlich dann gehört haben. Und das ist für den Bereich des Frauenfußballs. Ich habe mich da mit anderen Podcastern und Podcasterinnen drüber unterhalten. Also das sollen wohl nach allem, was ich gehört habe, ganz fantastische Zahlen sein. Also wir haben ja sowieso sehr gute Zahlen für einen Fußball-Podcast, trotz all der Konkurrenz da draußen. Aber für den Frauenfußball gilt das, glaube ich, insbesondere. Und bei den Kurzpässen ist es so, dass ein Kurzpass zur zweiten Liga meistens so bei 15.000 liegt, eine Ligatur meistens so bei 12.000 bis 13.000. Ich beziehe mich jetzt immer auf die letzten Folgen, weil die sehe ich jetzt hier gerade. Und wir sind im Frauenfußball, kratzen wir immer zwischen 9.000 und 10.000. Also da ist kein großer Abfall zu sehen. Und das Feedback vor allem auf die Kurzpässe ist so gut, dass ich mir auch sicher bin, dass es zumindest viele Leute hören. Bestimmt nicht alle dieser 9.000. Klar, tun es aber bei den anderen Folgen auch nicht. Aber das Feedback ist sehr gut. Gerade die Interviews mit den Spielerinnen. Man sieht so ein bisschen, was der Rasenfunk noch so alles sein könnte, wenn der Männerfußball nicht so wäre, wie er wäre. Wenn man auch da an Leute rankommen würde. Wie toll man einfach mit Fußballerinnen und Trainerinnen und sportlichen Leiterinnen über ihren Sport reden kann, wenn das im Männerfußball auch möglich wäre. Wie anders man den Rasenfunk machen könnte, das sieht man an den Kurzpässen. Das ist auch das Feedback, was ich viel bekomme. Also ich bekomme sehr viel Feedback auf die Interviews, die ja in den Kurzpässen mit dabei sind und die jedes für sich interessant war in dieser Hinrunde.
Da würde ich gleich noch eine Frage anschließen. Ich springe jetzt ein bisschen im Thread und ich hoffe, ich vergesse die Frage von Alex oben nicht gleich. Aber Rade hat gefragt, und das passt hier gerade so wunderbar, mich würde auch interessieren, wie der Rasenfunk insgesamt in der Frauenfußball-Community ankommt. Ich fand die Interviews in den Kurzpässen zur Frauenbundesliga richtig gut. Es irritiert mich, dass es scheinbar trotzdem sehr schwierig ist, passende Gesprächspartnerinnen zu finden. Ist der Rasenfunk keine Marke im Frauenfußball? Gibt es da Zurückmeldungen?
Schwer zu sagen, weil da spreche ich jetzt über etwas, was irgendwie nicht so klar definiert ist. Also was ist denn der Frauenfußballbereich? Also wo es klar definiert ist, das sind die Vereine. Und da muss ich sagen, dass da haben wir keinerlei Probleme gehabt, Interviews zu bekommen. Es gab zwar manchmal so terminliche Probleme und ich musste eben lernen, dass ich einen größeren Vorlauf brauche zum Anfragen. Und dass ich gewisse Vereine, die am Sonntag spielen, ich meine, das wusste ich schon, dass ich die nicht für eine Montagsaufnahme anfragen muss, weil da haben die Spielerinnen eben alle frei und sollen ja auch frei haben. Aber dass es auch zum Beispiel die Samstag-Teams betrifft und so weiter, das war mir so nicht klar, das habe ich gelernt. Aber ansonsten sehr positiv. Wir haben fast alle Interview-Gesprächspartnerinnen bekommen, die wir bekommen haben. Wenn etwas nicht geklappt hat, dann hatte es mit einer Ausnahme immer damit zu tun, dass es quasi terminliche Gründe hat. Also zum Beispiel der VfL Wolfsburg sagt, wir haben einen so vollen Terminkalender außerhalb von Pressekonferenzen, zu dem man sich ja zuschreiten könnte, machen wir gar keine einzelnen Interviews. Und das ist ja völlig zu respektieren. Sie haben ja wirklich einen dichten Terminkalender. Dann klappt das halt nicht. Vielleicht aber dann vor der Rückrunde der Frauen. Da bin ich in Gesprächen. Aber tatsächlich gab es gar keine Probleme. Ich glaube aber ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, dass das jetzt auch am Rasenfunk liegt, sondern dass da generell eine größere Aufgeschlossenheit gegenüber Medienterminen ist. Denn ich habe auch in vielen anderen Podcast-Spielerinnen gehört. Ich habe auf YouTube-Kanälen Interviews gehört. Und da gibt es glaube ich jetzt nicht so diese Reichweitenhürde, die es im Männerfußball definitiv gibt, dass wir halt da viel zu klein und unbekannt sind. Das ist glaube ich im Frauenfußball nicht so. Und in der weiteren Community weiß ich es nicht. Also was mir auffällt ist, das finde ich aber eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht, aber es war jetzt schon so, dass manche Spielerinnen im Rasenfunk Dinge gesagt hat, die im Männerfußball zu Anschlussberichterstattung geführt hätten. Weil das schon interessante Takes waren, wie man heutzutage so sagt. Ich fand das interessant, dass das bei Frauen überhaupt nicht passiert. Also kein einziges Medium hat auch nur irgendein Zitat aufgegriffen, auch nicht aus den anderen Podcasts, die ich gehört habe. Also bei der 45 zum Beispiel oder bei Raus aus dem Abseits waren auch interessante Interviews zu hören in diesem Jahr. Und bei dem Podcast Mittags bei Henning ist das ja schon ganz lange so, dass da immer wieder sehr, sehr interessante Aussagen mit dabei sind und die aber eigentlich nie so aus dieser Podcastwelt rauskommen. Das wäre im Männerfußball anders. Also wenn wir da einen Spieler haben, dann weiß ich, dass die beteiligten Vereinsjournalisten die Folgen dann doch hören, vielleicht auch manchmal zähneknirschen, weil sie sich ärgern, dass derjenige Spieler im Rasenfunk war. Das ist im Frauenfußball noch nicht passiert. Aber ist vielleicht nicht schlechtest. Denn eigentlich ist das ja der Grund, warum wir oft im Männerfußball keine Interviews bekommen, weil die Angst haben, dass ein Zitat rausgerissen wird aus einem langen Interview und dann die Runde macht.
Awe will jetzt noch wissen, auch im größeren Themenkomplex, angenommen Frauenfußball und Männerfußball wären gleich populär. Ihr beide müsstet euch aus Belastungsgründen für eines von beiden entscheiden.
Also wenn es jetzt quasi unter den jetzigen Bedingungen gleich populär wäre, Frauenfußball, denn A3-Spiele weniger am Wochenende und die Protagonistinnen sind halt viel...
Da ist die Frage, glaube ich, einfach. Aber das ist natürlich sehr theoretisch.
Sollen wir an der Stelle vielleicht, du hast es angedeutet, sollen wir die Feedfrage vielleicht auch beantworten, dass wir hier quasi den großen Frauenfußball-Block machen? Genau, denn dieses Gedankenexperiment von Awer, das ist eigentlich auch Ausgangspunkt, warum sich die Berichterstattung zum Frauenfußball im Rasenfunk verändert hat zu dieser Saison hin. Und zwar genau von der anderen Seite her gedacht. Also meiner persönlichen Meinung, das ist jetzt alles nur ganz subjektiv, aber meiner persönlichen Meinung nach gibt es kaum einen Grund, warum der Frauenfußball so viel weniger populär ist als der Männerfußball. Also dass es gleich auf ist, da kann man vielleicht noch irgendwelche Begründungen finden, also nicht gleich auf ist. Aber dass es eine so große Diskrepanz ist, das hat für mich, das kann keinen anderen Grund haben, als eben eine strukturelle Benachteiligung. Die Entwicklung des Frauenfußballs, die eben eine gehinderte Entwicklung war, von vielen externen Seiten aus. Und eben einer fehlenden Berichterstattung, die sich begründet haben lässt, also das ist dann so ein Henne-Ei-Problem, in der schlechten Reichweite, die der Frauenfußball hat. Also der Frauenfußball hat schlechte Reichweite, weil wenig über ihn berichtet wird, weil nämlich diese Berichte wenig Reichweite bekommen. Das ist eine meiner Grundüberzeugungen, zu denen ich gelangt bin und die dann zu der Frage geführt hat, ja Moment mal, jetzt sind wir doch eins von ganz wenigen Medien da draußen. Vielleicht sogar im Fußball, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht so mit das einzige Medium, was ja die Reichweite eben nicht als allerhöchstes Ziel von allem hat. Das einzige, was wir haben, ist, wir brauchen genügend Unterstützerinnen und Unterstützer. Das ist eine Zahl, die ist für uns wichtig. Und da wollen wir ja auch wachsen, haben wir ja vorhin besprochen. Aber ob jetzt eine Sendung von fünf Millionen Menschen oder von 5.000 Menschen gehört hat, hat ja eigentlich für uns nicht die riesige Relevanz. Also das ist ja eigentlich nicht der Kern des Rasenfunks. Und von diesem Gedankenexperiment ausgehend bin ich dann dazu gekommen, eigentlich muss gerade ein Medium wie der Rasenfunk, der sich eben bei so vielen anderen Dingen auf Reichweite, ich sag's jetzt einfach mal, scheißt und einfach sagt, ja klar reden wir drei Stunden über Männerbundesiegerspieltag. Wenn ihr es nicht wollt, dann hört halt was anderes, gibt ja genug. Eigentlich gerade deswegen müssen wir uns dann von so was lösen und müssen eben nicht auf die Reichweiten gucken. Und ich hab jetzt zum Beispiel auch die Reichweiten für die Frauensendungen, die hab ich nachgeguckt. Ich wusste die jetzt nicht, ich wusste, es passt halbwegs, aber mehr wusste ich dazu nicht. Und das war für mich einer der wesentlichen Gedankenanstöße, als ich mir gedacht habe, nein, das muss eigentlich hier im Rasenfunk einen möglichst gleichrangigen Platz zum Männerfußball bekommen. Denn es ist nicht anders erklärbar, warum wir bei den Männern immer so einen Aufriss machen und bei den Frauen nicht. Also was soll denn das?
Ja, man könnte das aber meinen, weil tatsächlich der gleichrangige Platz wäre ja auch ein zweiter Feed nebendran sozusagen. Wenn man sagt, man benennt dann vielleicht die Schlusskonferenz in Männer-Schlusskonferenz um und es gibt eine zweite, die als Frauenschlusskonferenz, dann wäre es ja irgendwie gleichrangig. Aber wir haben dann eben gesagt, okay, der Nachteil ist aber eben, dann fängt der Frauenfußball auch beim Rasenfunk von Null an. Und die Schlusskonferenz, wir haben vorhin gesagt, ein bisschen mehr als acht Jahre Rasenfunk jetzt. Man muss ja schon berücksichtigen, da stecken acht Jahre Wachstum drin. Und natürlich würde der neue Feed jetzt nicht komplett bei Null anfangen, weil man würde dann natürlich über bestehende Kanäle promoten. Aber der hätte es erstmal sehr schwer. Und darum haben wir uns dann im Sommer entschieden, dass zumindest jetzt mal für den Start des Frauenfußballs in höherer Präsenz beim Rasenfunk so zu belassen, weil wir gesagt haben, wir wollen schon, dass es sehr sichtbar ist für alle und wollen das daher in die bestehenden Feeds integrieren. Das hat dann auch noch andere Gründe. Wir haben jetzt gerade die Website neu gemacht, die sehr auf drei Feeds ausgelegt ist, in vielerlei Hinsicht da jetzt einen vierten oder fünften einzuführen. Wäre natürlich möglich, um Gottes Willen, aber wäre auch ein gewisser Aufwand. Jetzt gehen wir erstmal diesen Weg, auch weil die Entscheidung relativ kurz vor Start der Frauenbundesliga gefallen ist. Wir wollen auf jeden Fall zum Start der Frauenbundesligasaison da schon ein bisschen mehr machen.
Genau. Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, dass wir es deswegen ineinander fließen lassen, auch weil wir auch glauben, dass das vielen von euch gar nicht sauer ausstößt. Es gibt zwar einige Leute, die ärgern das sehr, das ist aber generell immer so, wenn man irgendwas mit Frauen macht. Das hatten wir schon immer in der Geschichte des Rasenfunks. Ich meine, dass so viele Frauen Gäste sind, das ist jetzt inzwischen kein Thema mehr. Also anscheinend gibt es da einen Gewöhnungseffekt. Ich würde sagen, ab Jahr 3 des Rasenfunks hat es eigentlich aufgehört, dass das ständig thematisiert werden musste. Zum Glück ist das jetzt kein Thema mehr. Jetzt ist der Frauenfußball gerade so ein Thema, wo dann manche Leute sich auch wirklich ärgern. Und das tut mir auch leid, ich möchte keine Leute verärgern. Ich möchte euch aber schon die Möglichkeit geben, da ähnlich reinzukommen, wie ich mich ja auch reingearbeitet habe. Hinweg von jemandem, der eben vor allem bei internationalen Turnieren Frauenfußball geguckt hat, das auch schon sehr lange, der aber auch viel zu wenig immer noch von der Frau im Bundesliga weiß. Und ich glaube, diese Möglichkeit wird eben auch höher, wenn es eben in die bestehenden Feats einfließt. Und man dann vielleicht doch mal, vielleicht sogar auch manchmal, ohne dass man es wollte, das ist natürlich dann schade, aber reingehört hat und dann merkt, ach da tut sich was. Und zum Beispiel bekommen so auch alle mit, ey, ist ja interessant, hier sind auf einmal Fußballprofis im Rasenfunk zu hören, was ja sonst immer so der Heilige Gral so sein schien. Sonst, das bekommt man jetzt einfach mit. Und das finde ich, ist ein Aspekt, den sollte man nicht unterschätzen. Und einen letzten Gedanken habe ich dazu noch, dann darfst du gerne auch nochmal, wenn du noch irgendwas hast. In einer idealen Welt wäre es für mich so, dass überall, egal ob auf kicker.de, sport1.de und so weiter und so fort, Fußball einfach Fußball ist. Und ich hätte überhaupt kein Problem damit, wenn da eine Meldung zu Alex Popp neben einer Meldung zu Thomas Müller steht. Im selben Bereich nämlich Bundesliga. Ich fände das überhaupt nicht schlimm. Und wenn man mal rumguckt in anderen Sportarten, ist das auch ganz oft so, dass es da eben gar nicht diese krassen Kategorien gibt. Denn Fußball ist Fußball. Und auch da ist es so, dass die Meldung zu Thomas Müller wahrscheinlich noch mehr Leute interessiert als Alex Popp, aber trotzdem können die doch nebeneinander stehen. Deswegen finde ich es eigentlich auch schön, wenn es im Rasenfunk so wäre. Ob das für immer so bleibt, wissen wir aber nicht. Auch da gucken wir drauf und hören vor allem auch auf euer Feedback. Wir haben aber auch viel positives Feedback dazu bekommen. Deswegen würde ich sagen, es hält sich mindestens die Waage. Beziehungsweise eigentlich das Positive überwiegt dann doch noch aktuell.
Ja, ich hab dem eigentlich gar nicht so viel hinzuzufügen. Den letzten Punkt wollte ich noch mal unterstreichen. Bitte diskutiert mit uns drüber, wie wir das ja eigentlich bei allen Dingen machen. Wollen wir euch herzlich einladen und damit machen. www.rasenfunk.de ist unser Forum. Da herrscht eine ganz tolle Diskussionskultur. Bitte, wenn ihr Kritik habt oder auch Lob, egal in welcher Form ihr unser Feedback geben wollt, da ist der beste Platz. Da könnt ihr auch mit anderen Hörern diskutieren. Da könnt ihr eure eigene Meinung so ein bisschen bouncen mit den anderen Hörern und mal reinhören, was die so drüber denken. Wir sind auch die Letzten, die da nicht offen für Änderungen sind. Wenn ihr konkrete Vorschläge habt, wie wir mit dem einen oder anderen Thema noch besser umgehen können, bitte immer her damit. Da sind wir immer diskussionsbereit.
Stimmt, das ist noch ein letzter Punkt, den müssen wir noch kurz erwähnen. Da haben wir schon drüber gesprochen, wir zwei. Deswegen haben wir es jetzt, glaube ich, beide vergessen. Die Kennzeichnung ist noch ein Thema. Ich dachte bisher, es wäre eindeutig, dass quasi alles mit einem Hashtag vor einer Zahl im Kurzpass fiel, dass das ein Frauenbundesligaspietag ist. Offenbar scheint es aber doch ein Thema für den ein oder anderen von euch zu sein. Und da überlegen wir jetzt, ob wir die Kennzeichnung verändern. Würde dann bedeuten, dass dann wahrscheinlich hinter jeder Männerfußball-Sendung ein, in Klammern, M dahinterstünde, hinter dem Titel und bei den Frauen ein, in Klammern, W. Wie genau wir es machen, müssten wir noch mal gucken. Das ist allerdings ein Thema. Wenn da Leute von euch tatsächlich durcheinanderkommen, dann ist es ja kein Problem, dass wir uns da drauf anpassen.
Genau, da muss man vielleicht dazu erwähnen, dass die Titellänge wirklich ein Problem ist, weil lange Titel zwar möglich sind, aber dann in Podcatchern abgeschnitten werden und so. Drum haben wir schon damals den 9. Spieltag gegen dieses Hash-Symbol ausgetauscht, um kürzere Kommunikationsformen zu haben quasi im Titel. Wir wissen natürlich auch, dass es nicht einfacher wird, vor allem für Menschen, die den Rasenfunk nicht kennen. Wenn wir jetzt anfangen mit Buchstaben und Zahlen und würden Kombinationen, die dann irgendwann aussehen, wie ein Passwort im Podcast-Titel zu agieren. Insofern, wie Max schon sagt, sind wir dann noch nicht ganz sicher, wie es aussehen soll. Aber auch hier euer Feedback jederzeit immer gerne. Und dann gucken wir uns zusammen an, was wir dafür eine gute Lösung finden.
Und vielleicht noch als allerletztes der eine Hinweis. Der erste Satz in den Show Notes ist immer die exakte Beschreibung, was in der Folge stattfindet. Und da steht auch immer mit dabei, Männer und Frauen. Das heißt, eigentlich kann man es auch sehr schnell auf einen Blick sehen, nur halt eben nicht nur im Titel. Und jetzt müssen wir überlegen, ist es uns das wert, dass wir die Titel alle nochmal aufbohren und verschandeln, also schön sieht es nicht aus, wenn überall dann nochmal geklammelt wird. Weißt du, was wir machen, Frank? Wir nehmen einfach Emojis. Und die werden dann in manchen Podcasts dann nicht angezeigt. Da ist es dann das Kästchen mit dem Fragezeichen. Dann ist es quasi wie bei, was wollen sie nehmen, Tor 1, Tor 2 oder die Kiste, die Kiste, die Kiste, die Kiste.
Ich scroll jetzt mal wieder hoch zu Alex. Alexmox86, grüße Alex, den ich beinahe vergessen hätte. Unglaublich, sagt er, dass diese Frage noch nicht kam, ist noch ein Klassiker und gehört daher gestellt. Plant ihr neues Merch? Wie zufrieden seid ihr aktuell mit eurem Partner? Danke Alex für deine Frage.
Also an der Merchfront ist es so geblieben, wie wir es glaube ich in der letzten Q&A-Folge auch schon mal länger besprochen haben. Also jetzt einfach erstmal von der Einnahmenseite her gesprochen. Das Merch ist kein weiteres finanzielles Standbein für uns, weil sich herausgestellt hat, das was wir einnehmen durch Verkäufe, reinvestieren wir dann in die Vorproduktion neuer Produkte und dann nehmen wir daraus wieder Einnahmen ein und die stecken wir dann in neue Produkte. Und ich habe inzwischen Rücksprache gehalten mit anderen Podcasterinnen und Podcastern, die auch Merch anbieten. Und es scheint überall ähnlich zu sein, wenn man...
Von denen wir dachten, dass sie sich eine goldene Nase damit verdienen.
Genau, wir dachten natürlich, dass sie da... Aber es scheint eben einfach zu sein, dass wenn man eben nicht irgendwie die, keine Ahnung, 4-Euro-Shirts für 30 Euro verkauft, sondern eben halt nachhaltig und fair produziert und so weiter und so fort, da sollte ich auch noch gleich kurz was zu sagen, dann ist das einfach so, dann sind die Margen zu klein. Und das ist dann auch nicht schlimm, bedeutet aber auch, wir müssen es dann entsprechend gewichten. Das heißt, unser Tag sieht jetzt nicht so aus, dass wir 8 Stunden davon jeden Tag über einen neuen Merch nachdenken, sondern wenn jetzt mal wieder ein Artikel ausverkauft ist, jetzt haben wir immerhin die letzte Cap endlich mal verkauft, dann denken wir drüber nach, was wir wieder machen. Aber es wird keine großen Drops geben mit irgendwie 5-Shirt-Design oder so. Das ist einfach nicht rentabel für uns. Ja, ich wollte dir die Möglichkeit geben, mich abzugrätschen, wenn ich irgendwas falsch wiedergegeben hab. Wir hatten ja natürlich noch diese sehr große Thematik, dass wir bei Global Tactics waren, oder auch immer noch sind, kann ich gleich sagen. Wir sind bei ihnen geblieben, zu denen es ja den Jan Böhmermann Beitrag gab. Wer sich dafür interessiert, dazu haben wir im letzten Jahr oder im Januar, oder wann immer das rauskam, haben wir das thematisiert. Wir haben auf Twitter dazu uns gesagt, und ich hab auch in irgendeiner Schlusskonferenz nochmal ein extra Einleitungssegment gemacht. Und da hatten wir euch ja gesagt, dass wir das sehr ernst nehmen, denn da gab es eben einen Beitrag, der darauf schließen ließ, dass es im Zuge einer anderen Produkte, in Zusammenarbeit mit Fink-Liemann, eben nicht so war, dass die hergestellten Produkte aus der EU kamen und unter den Bedingungen hergestellt waren, wie es Global Tactic eigentlich öffentlich kommuniziert hat. Und dann mussten wir natürlich überprüfen, wie ist das bei uns. Und was sagt das eigentlich über Global Tactic als Auftraggeber? Und das haben wir sehr ausführlich getan, hat auch eine ganze Weile gedauert, aber wir wollen uns bei sowas auch Zeit nehmen und konnten zu unserer Beruhigung feststellen, also zum einen ist es so, unsere Produkte kamen und kommen immer schon aus der EU. In Zukunft werden wir das aber besser dokumentieren, dass es auch eindeutig ist. Wir haben es jetzt allerdings für jedes Produkt nachvollziehen können. Für die Hoodies habe ich dann schon quasi darauf reagiert. Und da könnt ihr ein PDF sehen, wo das noch mal dokumentiert wird. Ich muss das endlich für die anderen Merchandise-Artikel noch nachliefern. Aber wir wissen und waren uns da auch schon immer relativ sicher, weil alles hat darauf hingedeutet, die Dinge, die wir verkaufen, die kommen eben aus Serbien, die Hoodies und aus Portugal. Das waren dann, bevor ich es jetzt falsch sage, also Shirts waren es definitiv. Bei Caps bin ich mir gerade nicht sicher. Aber sie sind ja eh zum Glück gerade schon ausverkauft. Zum anderen ist es so, dass wir sehr lange mit den Verantwortlichen sprechen konnten, die inzwischen auch ein anderes Unternehmen gegründet haben. Sowohl Finn Kliemann als auch Tom Ilbrook, die wesentlichen Protagonisten bei diesen Masken-Deals, die sind in keiner Weise an diesen Firmen beteiligt. Und sie waren auch quasi in geschäftsführender Situation. Waren sie auch schon länger nicht mehr beteiligt. Und uns konnte aber, und das war eigentlich so mit das Erleichternste, glaube ich für uns beide, uns konnte sehr glaubhaft versichert werden, dass von den Personen, mit denen wir jetzt zusammenarbeiten und die jetzt auch die Entscheidungen treffen bei Daedalus, so heißt das Unternehmen, die waren alle, glaube ich sogar damals noch gar nicht bei Global Tactics, als all diese Dinge passiert sind. Und das war somit die größte Erleichterung. Und deswegen konnten wir dann auch guten Gewissens bei ihnen bleiben, weil wir eben gesehen haben, es wird besser dokumentiert, es wird transparenter, wir können uns sicher sein, dass das, was drauf steht, auch quasi drin ist, nämlich eine möglichst nachhaltige und faire Produktion. Und eben es gibt jetzt auch keinen moralischen Vorbehalte gegen irgendwelche handelnden Akteure da, denn die waren so eigentlich ja alle. Also man kann es nicht ausschließen, dass im Lager irgendjemand noch arbeitet, der damals auch mal eine Kiste aus Bangladesch in der Hand hatte. Aber da ist auch die Frage, wie man das ehrlich gesagt gewichten möchte, wenn da jemand dann wahrscheinlicher Anordnung...
Also es ist auf jeden Fall aus unserer Sicht quasi ist der jetzige Status sehr akzeptabel und sehr gut und man muss ja dazu sagen, die Zusammenarbeit war eigentlich auch schon die ganze Zeit sehr gut, was für uns auch mit ein Grund war, wo wir gesagt haben, okay, das zu ändern, also wir haben immer gehofft, dass wir es zu einer positiven Erkenntnis bringen können für uns und die Zusammenarbeit fortsetzen können, weil natürlich dort den Anbieter wechseln und dann ist ja das Potential, dass es da gar nicht so gut funktioniert, wie es bis dato funktioniert hatte, wäre für uns auch ein Riesenwurf gewesen. Und insofern waren wir sehr froh, dass wir das Ganze jetzt so zu positiven Erkenntnissen gekommen sind sozusagen, was die Zusammenarbeit angeht. Die ganze Sache war übrigens im Mai, Max, die Böhmermann-Nummer. Und ich überleg grad, ob wir das Ganze nicht gerade schon zum zweiten Mal erzählen.
Ja, ehrlicherweise weiß ich mir auch nicht, ob wir das Ganze noch nicht im Rasenfunk Royale erzählen. Ja, ergibt ihr aufsehen.
Aber macht ja nix. Ist ja gar nicht so schlimm, weil wir hören ja jetzt vielleicht noch einige, die es damals nicht gehört haben. Also ihr könnt euch sicher sein, wir schauen da jetzt noch mal genauer hin. Und uns liegt natürlich auch viel daran, dass wir euch da keinen Quatsch erzählen und dass die Produkte tatsächlich fair produziert sind. Und da gucken wir so gut hin, so gut es uns möglich ist. Und sind da auch zufrieden. Weil die Frage von Alex war ja, wie zufrieden wir aktuell mit unserem Partner sind. Und da sind wir tatsächlich sehr zufrieden.
Exakt. Und keine Zweifel haben wir. Und wenn alle Zweifel ausgeräumt werden, dann hat man auch ein Gefühl der Sicherheit zurückerlangt.
Genau. Dann machen wir mal weiter mit dem lieben Zaunpfahl. Ein Stammgast im Forum. Der Rasenfunk ist ja, sagt er, soweit ich das mitbekommen habe, schon bei einigen Fußballspielen offiziell akkreditiert auf der Pressetribüne gewesen. Dazu zwei Fragen. Erstens, was ist eigentlich der Vorteil, wenn man Journalist selbst beim Spiel anwesend ist? Max nimmt ja extra die An- und Abreise in Kauf, wobei Zeit am Wochenende vermutlich eher eine stark begrenzende Ressource ist. Daher nehme ich an, dass das Stadionerlebnis einen Vorteil gegenüber dem Scouting-Feed hat.
Ja, also, Scouting-Feed habe ich ja gar nicht. Den gibt es ja nur beim Samstagabend-Topspiel. Ansonsten habe ich keinen Zugriff auf den Scouting-Feed, sondern nur auf die normalen Fernsehbilder, die ihr auch seht. Und das ist dann auch schon der Vorteil. Fußball ist immer besser zu analysieren, wenn man im Stadion ist, weil man da eben immer die 22-Kamera hat. Also alle 22 Feldspieler sofort auf einen Blick sieht und eben auch Dinge aufnehmen kann, die von den Kameras nicht eingefangen werden. Das ist der eine große Vorteil, wenn man im Stadion ist. Der zweite große Vorteil ist, man hat die Möglichkeit, in der Mixed Zone mit Spielern zu sprechen und man kann den Trainern Fragen stellen. Und da habe ich sehr große Lust drauf, weil ich ja auch immer Fragen habe nach Spielen. Das sind die beiden großen Vorteile, weshalb es sich für mich lohnt, in Stadien zu gehen und die auch dann Mehrwert bieten, auch für die Analyse im Rasenfunk. Und den großen Nachteil hat Soundfarm schon völlig richtig erkannt, wie auch nicht anders zu erwarten von einem Stammhörer. Der Zeitaufwand ist der Grund, warum ich das nicht an jedem Wochenende mache, sondern sehr, sehr ausgewählt bisher. Denn eben in der Zeit, in der ich zu einem Stadion fahre, von einem Stadion wegfahre, in der Mixed Sound warte, auf die Pressekonferenz warte, kann ich mindestens zwei weitere Spiele gucken. Plus ich sehe ja dann diesmal nur ein Spiel, habe nicht auf einem zweiten Bildschirm noch eins mitlaufen. Das heißt, in der Regel verliere ich drei Spiele, die ich dann wann anders gucken muss. Das schränkt mich halt sehr dabei ein, wann ich mal im Stadion sein kann. Also eben als Beispiel, wenn der FC Bayern, also München liegt natürlich nahe, weil ich eben in München wohne, München und Augsburg wären so die Möglichkeiten, als erstes Mal irgendwo ins Stadion zu gehen. Wenn die am Samstag oder am Sonntag spielen, ist es so gut wie ausgeschlossen. Ich war einmal beim Samstagabend Spiel zwischen Bayern und Gladbach. Und das habe ich bitter bereut, weil ich erst sehr spät wieder zu Hause war und dann noch anfangen musste, die ganzen anderen Samstagsspiele nachzugucken. Ich konnte irgendwie noch die erste Halbzeit von den 1530-Spielen sehen, aber sonst nichts. Und bei Freitagabendspielen, da ginge es mal. Aber ansonsten, der Zeitverlust ist tatsächlich da. Und deswegen passiert das nur auch so sporadisch.
Dann schließt er noch an und wir wissen, wie so eine Pressetribüne eigentlich aussieht.
Das ist unterschiedlich. Also auf jeden Fall Stuhltisch, Internet und Strom ist inzwischen eigentlich bei allen mit dabei. Und dann hast du in manchen Bundesliga-Standorten hast du Bildschirme, auf denen dann auch das Signal des übertragenen Senders durchläuft. Das hat insofern den Vorteil, dass man da einen zeitlichen Versatz von so ungefähr zwei Sekunden drin hat. Das ist sehr günstig, weil man hat quasi die strittige Szene gesehen und kann sie dann gleich bewerten und hat noch mal die Nahaufnahme, die einem ja sonst im Stadion fehlt. Es gibt aber auch Stadien, da gibt es nur einige wenige Monitore. Ein paar brauchen die natürlich, also die Kommentatorinnen und Kommentatoren, die haben immer noch mal Monitore, die müssen ja auch sehen, was der Zuschauer und die Zuschauerin sehen kann. Und dann ist es sehr unterschiedlich. Also beim FC Bayern zum Beispiel, da habe ich dann keinen Monitor.
Jetzt haben wir ganz viel Diskussion im Forum. Ich hoffe, ich übersehe nichts, aber der nächste, der mir mit einer Frage direkt aufkommt, ist der Arribo. Grüße an dieser Stelle. Auch ein langjähriger Stammhörer und Stamm-User im Forum. Wie stark will er wissen, war die Entscheidung zur GmbH von den häufiger zitierten Problemen mit dem Finanzamt getrieben? Kann man eigentlich sagen, gar nicht, oder?
Naja, ein bisschen schon, ehrlich gesagt. Also mir ist das schon alles hart auf den Sack gegangen, um das jetzt mal so zu sagen. Und ich bin auch mit dem Ergebnis der Prüfung nicht zufrieden. Nein, ja, ich hoffe dann doch. Weil irgendwie hab ich das Gefühl, dass ein Teil dieses ganzen Heckmarks mit dem Finanzamt auch damit zu tun hatte, dass ich vor dem Finanzamt halt quasi einfach ein Dude bin, der von ganz vielen Dudes und Dudettes da draußen Geld überwiesen bekommt. Und ich hoffe, dass es ein bisschen besser wird, wenn das jetzt eine GmbH ist, den Geld überwiesen bekommt. Kann doch sein, dass ich da sehr blauäugig bin. Vielleicht glaube ich da zu sehr an das Kompetente im Finanzbeamten. Es tut mir leid, ich muss es einfach so sagen. Diese ganze Steuerprüfungsnummer und so weiter war einfach... Ich bin nach wie vor nicht happy damit. Ich kann ja nichts dafür, dass wir so ein tolles Finanzierungsmodell haben, was einfach auf Nettigkeit basiert.
Ja, es ist tatsächlich wahrscheinlich wirklich das Ungewöhnliche daran, wie wir das ja vorhin schon erwähnt haben, dass dieses Thema der freiwilligen, gegenleistungsfreien Spenden, die für das Finanzamt im Unternehmenskontext eher ungewöhnlich sind.
Erst dachten sie Geldwäsche, dann dachten sie, wir bescheißen sie. Und dann haben sie ganz, ganz ausführlich in unsere Bücher reingeguckt, die natürlich völlig sauber waren. Warum sollten wir da irgendwas irgendwie faken wollen? Wir wollen ja alles richtig machen und haben dann festgestellt, ach so, dann bist du kein Unternehmer. Du hast ja gar keine Gewinnerzielungsabsicht, weil du machst ja die Sendung trotzdem. Und naja. Und das, denke ich, wird jetzt mit der GmbH schon ein bisschen schwieriger, uns jetzt zu sagen, dass wir keine Unternehmer sind. Bin ich mal gespannt.
Außerdem will er noch die Merchfrage von Alex ergänzen um die Frage, wann der Rasenfunkturs endlich kommt.
Ja, Frank.
So, jetzt muss ich gucken, wo wir noch mal weiter. Zaunpfahl hat noch mal angehängt. Habt ihr Erwartungen bzw. Erfahrungen von anderen Podcastern, wie viele Daueraufträge nicht umziehen? Methodisch inkorrekt hat er ja auch schon mehrere, Fragezeichenkontowechsel hattet ihr mit denen Kontakt. Also wir haben grundsätzlich mit den Jungs von Methodisch inkorrekt immer mal Kontakt. Ich hatte da schon mehrfach Kontakt. Aber wir haben jetzt nicht explizit deswegen nachgefragt, oder Max?
Ich hab auch nicht nachgefragt. Also ganz liebe Grüße an die beiden. Aber da gab es eher andere Themen zuletzt, die auch wichtiger waren.
Wir haben keine konkreten Erwartungen. Wir befürchten leider, wie schon erwähnt, dass uns da ein gewisser Prozentsatz abhanden kommen wird. Wie viel ist es, können wir jetzt noch nicht sagen. Aber tatsächlich hängt das auch sehr stark von der Hörerschaft ab. Da sind jetzt Erfahrungen wahrscheinlich gar nicht so sehr hilfreich. Wir tun jetzt einfach, was wir können, indem wir euch aktiv und hoffentlich nicht zu aggressiv an mehreren Stellen informieren und darauf hinweisen. Max wird das sicherlich auch in den kommenden Sendungen tun. Die Geschichte mit den Einsend-Überweisungen hat Max ja vorhin auch schon erwähnt. Das ist eben auch so ein Weg, um diejenigen zu erwischen, von denen wir sonst keine Kontaktdaten haben. Jetzt hoffen wir einfach mal drauf. Ich glaube, dass wir da im ersten Vierteljahr 2023 sehen werden, wie sich das entwickelt. Es wird auch mit Sicherheit ein paar Monate dauern. Und leider, wie auch schon erwähnt, sind dann die Spenden, die Anfang des Jahres noch auf dem alten Konto landen für uns. Zwar trotzdem schön, aber erst mal ein bisschen problematisch, weil wir die nicht so einfach in die GmbH kriegen und auch nicht mehr so einfach für Gästehonorare verwenden können. Genau. Also insofern, wir wissen es nicht genau, wir sind besorgt. Aber gute Dinge, dass wir das hinbekommen.
Genau, wir freuen uns immer schon wahnsinnig über jede Überweisung, die aufs neue Konto reinkommt. Also ich denke, dir geht es genauso. Ich habe meine Push-Notifications noch an, weil ich das eben sehen will, wie viel kommt auf das neue Konto schon an.
An der Stelle ist der Thread dann etwas eskaliert. Alex hat noch den Max und Frank Wackelkopf als Merchartikel gefordert und die Belle wollte einen Baby-on-Board-Autosticker mit deinem Kopf drauf. Auf einem Babykörper. Ich will das gar nicht weiter kommentieren. Ich habe dann an der Stelle zwischendrin zur Ordnung gerufen im Thread. Und dann ging es noch ein bisschen weiter. Hammes Millner, der hat natürlich noch gefehlt als regelmäßiger Fragesteller in diesen Q&As. Er fragt allerdings nach den Auswirkungen des WM-Boykots, die wir schon besprochen haben an dieser Stelle. Er will aber auch noch wissen, was die Pläne für den Rasenfunk 2023 sind.
Glaub ich. Also jetzt erstmal das bestehende Programm soll weitergehen. Es wird dann eine Frauen-WM-Berichterstattung geben, wie die aussieht. Da bin ich aber in meinem Kopf schon am Planen, aber noch nicht. Meine Hände sind noch nicht am Planen. Ich hab noch keine Mails und so weiter verschickt. Und alles weitere muss man sehen. Aber ich denke, ihr könnt davon ausgehen, dass das, was ihr jetzt im letzten Halbjahr erlebt habt, das soll eigentlich der Rasenfunk 2023 sein. Das heißt, viele Kurzpässe, viele Schlusskonferenzen und immer mal wieder Tribünengespräche. So wie es in einer perfekten Rasenfunkwelt auch sein sollte.
Er will außerdem noch wissen, ob du schon etwas zu den Vorverkäufen beim Ulli-Buch sagen kannst oder darfst. Wie es da läuft, er drückt die Daumen für einen Platz in den Top 20. Die Chancen dafür sind in der ersten Woche immer besonders hoch, da dort dann auch alle Vorbestellungen mitgezählt werden. Er nennt das dann Buchbranchen-Hack.
Korrekt, das ist absolut korrekt. Ich habe keinerlei Überblick.
Ich kann sprechen, was dazu sagen.
Ich habe keine Vorverkaufszahlen, denn auch der Verlag hat keine Vorverkaufszahlen. Das hat mich ehrlicherweise selber etwas überrascht. Es ist so, dass der Verlag sieht, wie viele Exemplare wurden von den Buchhändlerinnen und Buchhändlern vorbestellt, aber das sind ja noch nicht verkaufte Exemplare. Und die Zahl ist halt wunderbar hoch. Aber das heißt halt leider gar nichts. Ich weiß deswegen nichts, bin selbst ganz überrascht. Ich hoffe auch sehr, dass man in, also die relevanteste Bestsellerliste ist ja die Spiegelbestsellerliste. Wenn man da draufkommt, dann hat man die Chance, dass dann ein Buch quasi so ein Selbstläufer wird. Also das Ziel des Buches wäre es, quasi auszubrechen aus unserer Blase und eben auch Leute zu erreichen, die weder den Rasenfunk kennen noch Elfleben kennen, die einfach nur wegen der Sache sich für das Buch interessieren. Und dafür müsste man aber so ein bisschen Durchhaltevermögen haben. Also in der ersten Woche reinkommen in die Bestsellerliste und dann aber hoffentlich auch drinbleiben, denn dann liegt man in den Buchhandlungen eben anders präsentiert. Dann hat man auch mal Laufkundschaft und dann müssen wir den Leuten ja noch genügend Zeit geben, dass sie diese 400 Seiten lesen und dann noch jemandem anderen empfehlen. Also deswegen, das sind sehr viele Dans und sehr viele eher konditionale als temporäre Dans. Also es ist nicht zu erwarten, dass das Uli-Buch irgendwie zum Bestseller wird und bleibt vor allem. Ich habe im Sportradio 360 darüber gesprochen, dass Caro Simon mir sofort das Du angeboten hat und dass das ein sehr, sehr schönes Interview war. Aber ich mir im Nachhinein gefragt hab, ob ich vielleicht zu wenig Journalist war in dem Moment. Weil ich eigentlich eben Leute, also ich sieht sie immer, alle Gäste im Rasenfunk. Außer eben es wird explizit irgendwie vorher von ihnen angesprochen, dass sie duzen wollen, weil ich eben dieses Angeduze nicht mag. Ich kenne ja die Leute nicht. Und ich will denen ja respektvoll begegnen und vielleicht auch kritisieren. Und das habe ich da angesprochen. Und deswegen hat er gesagt, ab jetzt siehst du mich nur noch.
Okay, gut, dann schreibt er, wenn ich das neulich bei Sporträder 360 richtig verstanden habe, dann wird sich Max Jakob aus der Zukunft alle Spiele eines Spieltags der ersten Fußballbundesliga der Männer und Frauen in Deutschland ansehen, um anschließend zwei separate Schlusskonferenzen bzw. eine Schlusskonferenz und einen Kurzpass dazu machen zu können. Nun meine Frage, was bedeutet das für Formate wie den Kurzpass oder das Tribünengespräch, aber auch Sondersendungen wie den Royal oder anders formuliert? Gab es die Überlegung, dass nicht auch eine andere Person als Max Jakob Ost die erste Fußballbundesliga der Männer oder der Frauen in Deutschland für den Rasenfunk machen könnte? Ich befürchte nämlich, dass aufgrund der Doppelbelastung des Max Jakob Ost die kleineren Formate wie auch eventuelle Sonderfolgen, ähnlich wie damals als 11 Leben priorisiert wurde, etwas zu kurz geraten könnten, was mich persönlich sehr dauerte, da mir die genannten Formate sehr viel Freude beim Hören bereiten und sie zudem anders als die meisten Schlusskonferenzen recht gut altern, wie ich finde. Deshalb, weshalb ich immer wieder einmal zum Beispiel in den alten Royal hineinhöre.
Ja, also das Gute ist, wir haben ja quasi schon eine Fallzahlgröße, nämlich die letzten Monate war das ja schon so, dass ich 15 Spiele pro Wochenende gesehen habe und dann diese Sendung gemacht habe. Und da würde ich sagen, hat kein Format in irgendeiner Weise gelitten. Es gab weiter Ligatouren, es gab weiter Sendungen zur zweiten Männerbundesliga und es gab auch Tribünengespräche. Und eins davon ist ja schon aufgenommen, aber noch nicht veröffentlicht aus verschiedenen Gründen. Also ich habe ja sogar noch eins mehr gemacht, als die Hörerinnen und Hörer bisher hören könnten. Also bisher hat das wunderbar geklappt und war eben nicht so wie bei LF Leben, wo eben manche Dinge zum Stillstand gekommen sind. Ganz im Gegenteil eigentlich finde ich. Also gerade bei der Legatur haben wir jetzt noch eine bessere Regelmäßigkeit reinbekommen. Und dennoch hat er aber total recht, dass es eigentlich zu viel ist. Es ist eigentlich auch nicht gut, 15 Spiele innerhalb von, naja es ist nicht immer am Wochenende, am Montag gucke ich meistens auch noch mal zwei Frauenspiele oder ein Frauenspiel. Aber das ist zu viel, das weiß ich auch. Das soll auch nicht für immer so sein. Und in meinem Kopf habe ich da schon ganz viele in denen gehabt, wer mal so moderieren könnte, neben mir, dass ich das nicht immer an einem Wochenende alles machen muss. Aber da hängen ja noch ganz viele andere Sachen dran. Geld unter anderem, also das haben wir ja vorhin schon angesprochen, da müsste sich noch ein bisschen was tun. Aber ich würde jetzt schon mal davon ausgehen, gewöhnt euch an den Gedanken, dass nicht immer der Max der Moderator ist. Weil so wie es aktuell ist, wie der Rasenfunk ist und wie wir wollen, dass er ist, geht es irgendwann nicht mehr, weil es einfach zu viele Sendungen sind und zu viel. Und dann leidet vielleicht auch irgendwann die Qualität. Also das ist ja jetzt auch gar nicht irgendwie nur aus Sicht von uns gedacht, sondern auch aus eurer Sicht gedacht. Also gewöhnt euch mal an den Gedanken, es wird bestimmt auch in 2023 wieder andere Moderatorinnen und Moderatoren im Rasenfunk geben.
Und das Ziel, das haben wir ja im Kontext der GmbH schon erwähnt, ist tatsächlich auch, das zu verstärken und da eventuell jetzt auch mehr Möglichkeiten zu haben, uns da Hilfe zu holen. Tasty Marshmallow, Marshmallow hat im Grunde das Ähnliche gefragt, darum überspringe ich den ersten Absatz mal. Dann kommt aber noch das zweite Frage, würde mich einfach interessieren, ob ihr in der Finanzierung eher eine ideale oder eine reale Lösung verfolgt. Allein die Umstellung auf die GmbH hat natürlich ein wenig mehr Interpretationsraum ermöglicht, aber mich würde mal abseits davon interessieren, habt ihr einen Großspender, der euch in ihren Gegenleistungen, einfach Geld freigibt? Es sind häufig die Bedingungen an Werbung geknüpft, was ihr ja nicht wollt. Ich kann mir einfach vorstellen, dass ein bestimmter Organisatierer euch Geld zur Verfügung stellt ohne Gegenleistung. Habt ihr so etwas oder baut die freiwillige Spende tatsächlich nur auf einzelnen Beiträgen auf? Gerade in Bezug auf die Honorare finde ich das interessant. Kann ich mal direkt beantworten? Hätten wir auch gerne mehr.
Großspender?
Großspender, die uns ohne Gegenleistung einfach Geld frei geben.
Also wenn es ohne Gegenleistung wäre, dann könnte ich mich auch damit anfreunden. Ansonsten finde ich ehrlich gesagt eigentlich die Kleinspender geil.
Nein, es ist ja wunderbar. Wir wollen das ja natürlich so. Und insofern, um die Frage zu beantworten, verfolgen wir weiter die ideale Lösung, glaube ich, wenn ich das so richtig interpretiere. Und die ist aber für uns ganz real, nämlich seit 2016 mittlerweile. Und da gibt es keinen Großspender. Oder gibt es einen Max, von dem ich nichts weiß?
Du wärst ja der Erste, der davon erfahren würde. Nein, es gibt keinen Großspender. Und das soll ja auch genauso sein. Und das ist ja auch der große Vorteil. Denn wenn der Großspender dann aufhörte zu spenden, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, dann würde uns da ein großer Teil unserer Einnahmen fehlen. Und das soll eben nicht passieren. Deswegen ist auch die stabilere Variante. Wir haben natürlich eine große Variante in den Beträgen, die wir überwiesen bekommen haben. Also in meinem Kopf habe ich schon ein paar Großspenderinnen und Großspender. Die möchte ich ganz herzlich grüßen an dieser Stelle. Die nehme ich monatlich einfach sehr, sehr viel Geld überweisen. Aber das ist jetzt, glaube ich, nicht das, was er meint. Das sind nicht die Beträge, auf die er da angespielt hat, glaube ich. Es liegt immer noch unter einem Gästehonorat. Das könnte doch die neue Kategorie sein. Willst du Großspenderin werden, dann musst du mindestens einen Gästehonorat überweisen pro Monat.
Nee, also die Frage können wir klar verneinen. Das sieht beim Rasenfunk intern tatsächlich auch so aus, wie es nach außen aussieht. Wir bekommen ausschließlich die Hörerspenden. Und das sind ganz viele Einzelspenden. Und da sind wir auch sehr glücklich drüber. Der Punkt ist ja auch so ein psychologischer. Weil wir dadurch auch einfach immer das Gefühl haben, direkt von unseren Hörern bezahlt zu werden. Und nicht von einem Gönner, der dann, wenn es auch vielleicht vermeintlich ohne Gegenleistung ist, aber wo dann intern trotzdem immer ein gewisser Druck entsteht, wenn da mal ein Kommentar kommt oder so, das dann demjenigen recht zu machen. Also könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das ein Problem ist. Wir waren nie in der Situation, Gott sei Dank. Und insofern gebe ich Max auch recht. Es ist auch tatsächlich die angenehmere Variante, das so zu haben, wie es jetzt ist.
Und halt viel stabiler. Wir haben jetzt die Ungewissheit des Kontowechsels, die ist da. Und so eine kleine Ungewissheit, was macht die Rezession, die kommen wird? Aber im Großen und Ganzen habt ihr uns wieder und wieder bewiesen, dass ihr uns nicht fallen lasst. Und zwar nicht einer lässt uns nicht fallen, sondern ein paar Hundert lassen uns nicht fallen. Weil es bisher immer so war, dass auch nur eine Andeutung im Rasenfunk gereicht hat, dass sich an den Spenden etwas bewegt hat. Deswegen wollen wir das auch nicht überstrapazieren, weil wir wollen das nicht ausnutzen in irgendeiner Art und Weise. Aber deswegen mache ich mir auch tatsächlich für 2023 jetzt überhaupt gar keine Sorgen mehr. Vor ein paar Monaten war das noch ein bisschen anders. Als es so leicht nach unten ging, hatte ich ein bisschen Sorgen. Weil ich wusste, was ich gerne alles machen würde und wie viele Gäste ich gerne einladen würde. Aber jetzt mache ich mir gar keine Sorgen mehr. Weil ich weiß, zur Not sind das in drei Sendungen aufeinander mal eine Erwähnung und eine Bitte. Und dann werden genügend von euch quasi da sein, um es aufzufangen. Und das ist wirklich wie ein warmer Mantel. Und ich möchte noch mal ganz herzlich die Finanzbeamtin grüßen an dieser Stelle, die die Steuerprüfung durchgeführt hat. So ist es halt im Rasenfunk. Ich kann doch auch nichts dafür.
Doch, ziemlich viel kannst du dafür. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Jetzt will Alex nochmal ganz ernsthaft von mir wissen. Er schreibt, es gibt ja genug Leute, die Max kennen und ihm auch ab und an persönlich sagen, dass er sich mal etwas rausnehmen soll, wenn es zu viel wird. Sein Eindruck ist aber, die sind ja alle erfolglos damit. Daher die ganz ernste Frage an mich, gibt es rein theoretisch, ihr seid ja dann GmbH und auch formal gleichberechtigt, die Chance, dass du irgendwann mal sagst, stopp Max, das wird jetzt zu viel, du brauchst eine Pause und wir ersetzen dich jetzt in dieser Woche durch Eva Lothar, Mark oder wie noch immer. Nein, Alex, ich bin aufgrund der Gleichberechtigung leider nur gleichberechtigt und nicht mehr berechtigt und auch nicht weisungsbefugt. Insofern, mehr als ihm gut zureden kann ich dann im Zweifelsfall auch nicht.
Aber das tust du ja oft genug, Frank. Und komm, ein bisschen verfängt es doch auch. Ich habe einen Urlaub gemacht während der Zeit, das war doch wirklich toll.
Er klagt ja, ich nicht. Noch nicht. Genau, das war es dann eigentlich auch schon. Wir haben dann ein paar Kommentare, die jetzt aber glaube ich an der Stelle nicht sein müssen. Und ansonsten haben wir alle Fragen, soweit ich das sehe, beantwortet. Und sind durch.
Da ist das verrückt.
Für dieses Jahr.
Frank, ist das vielleicht das erste Mal, dass wir innerhalb der Zeit geblieben sind, die wir uns vorher vorgenommen haben?
Ja, wir haben anderthalb Stunden gesagt, wir sind jetzt bei 1.25. Das ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Gibt es noch was, was du den Hörern und Hörern sagen willst zum Jahresausklang?
Na ja, natürlich will ich mich bedanken. Also vor allem erstmal bei allen Hörern und Hörerinnen definitiv fürs Zuhören und fürs Mitdiskutieren im Forum, auf Social Media, überall. Und natürlich im Speziellen bei den Supporterinnen für die tolle Unterstützung. Ehrlich gesagt hätte ich persönlich auch mit mehr Rückgang gerechnet dieses Jahr. Freut mich sehr. Ich glaube eben auch durch die von dir schon erwähnte breite Masse, durch die vielen, dass das alles jetzt so gut verlaufen ist bis hierhin. Wir werden, wie du schon gerade erwähnt hast, wahrscheinlich in eine Rezession laufen. Und da muss man erstmal noch sehen, wie das läuft. Man muss jetzt sehen, wie es mit der Kontoumstellung läuft. Aber ich glaube, wir haben jetzt keinen Grund, übermäßig besorgt in die Zukunft zu gehen. Wir haben ein paar tolle Ideen für das nächste Jahr, worüber wir sicherlich in den kommenden Wochen und Monaten noch sprechen werden. Und ich glaube, der Rasenfunk wird ein noch spannenderes Projekt in Zukunft. Und da freuen wir uns sehr drauf, oder ich mich persönlich auch sehr drauf, das mit euch als Hörer und natürlich mit Max. Alles zu machen und zu gestalten.
Absolut, ich auch. Und dann möchte ich mich anschließen. Also ich glaube, gerade der letzte Punkt, den du gesagt hast, der ist nochmal ganz wichtig. In der Rückschau wird es glaube ich so sein, dass man mal auf die Geschichte des Rasenfunks blickt und sagt, naja, 2014 damals gegründet, 2016 damals das Support-Modell eingeführt. 2019 war dann das erste Jahr, in dem ich den Rasenfunk hauptberuflich gemacht habe, alle meine anderen Dinge zurückgefahren habe. Da hat sich dann eben auch, also all das, worüber wir jetzt sprechen, Kurzpässe und so weiter, das ist ja alles dann auch erst so wirklich gekommen, weil es dann erstmal auch ging. Und ich glaube tatsächlich, das nächste Ding wird sein in der Rückschau, dass wir dann sagen, und dann 2022 bzw. 2023, da kam die GmbH und dann ging es nochmal weiter. Und ich glaube, so wird man das alles sehen und ich finde das total toll, dass wir das machen, auch wenn es anstrengend ist und wir da immer die Dinge zedenken und so weiter und man eben so viel Ungewissheit hat. Aber Frank, solange wir die Sache zu zweit machen, weiß ich, wir kriegen das immer hin. Weil wir uns sehr gut ausgleichen, glaube ich, weil wir uns aufeinander verlassen können. Das ist schon echt sehr cool, dass es diesen Podcast schon so lange gibt und dass wir den so lange gemeinsam machen. Und ich sag mal so, mit dir würde ich zu jedem Notar laufen, um irgendwelche GmbHs zu begriffen, weil es immer Spaß gemacht hat.
Und wer jetzt genau zugehört hat, der weiß auch, 2025 wird der ganz große nächste Wurf kommen. Nach 16, 19, 22, kann es nur 2025 werden, wenn wir dann, keine Ahnung, unseren IPO feiern und an die Börse gehen. Keine Ahnung.
Jeden Maastrathaus getauft und richtet das ganze Ding zu Grunde innerhalb von drei Tagen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das dauert dann keine drei Jahre, sondern eher drei Tage, ja.
Ja, wer weiß, vielleicht war ich... Mein Ziel muss natürlich sein, dass ich 2024 dann bei der Zeremonie der Europameisterschaft, der Männer-Europameisterschaft in Deutschland, dass ich da auf dem Feld bin, wie ein anderer, viel zu bekannter Koch es jetzt beim WM-Finale war. Auch das habe ich mitbekommen, ohne jemals danach gefragt zu haben. Das ist mein Ziel. Und dann geht es 2025 natürlich richtig ab. Ich schicke dir danach einen Link, wenn du willst. Danke, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für ein fantastisches Rasenfunk-Jahr. Wir können auch deshalb so transparent sein, weil es uns immer gedankt wird von euch mit eben inhaltlich wertvollem Feedback darauf. Wir sind sehr stolz darauf, dass man so gut mit euch reden kann, dass auch immer noch das Forum so ein wunderschöner Ort in diesem Internet ist. Und das auch bei YouTube, das möchte ich jetzt mal ausdrücklich sagen, weil ich habe manchmal über YouTube geschimpft, ich finde auch bei YouTube gab es ganz fantastische Diskussionen in diesem Jahr und ich persönlich spüre da schon, dass sich da etwas gedreht hat, in der Art und Weise wieder kommentiert hat. Vielleicht ist es eine Folge dessen, dass ich manchmal ein bisschen draufgehauen habe an dieser Stelle. Vielleicht aber hat sich es auch einfach so entwickelt in jedem Fall. Ihr seid definitiv auch gemeint, liebe YouTube-Kommentatorinnen und Kommentatoren, vor allem Kommentatoren, seien wir ehrlich. Aber ja, das ist einfach schön, dass wir diesen schönen Ort haben. Vielen Dank euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Dann machen wir jetzt Schluss, Frank. Dann wünschen wir euch, wenn ihr das noch vor den Weihnachtstagen hört, wunderbare Feiertage. Wenn ihr andere Feiertage feiert, dann wünschen wir euch da einfach jetzt viel Erholung. Bleibt vor allem gesund, bleibt dem Rasenfunk treu. Und danke, dass ihr mit dabei wart. Frank, jetzt hast du noch die Möglichkeit.
Vielen, vielen Dank. Auch dir, Max. Schöne Feiertage euch allen. Und einen guten Rutsch ins neue Jahr.
Einen guten Rutsch. Macht's gut, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer.
Das war die Rasenfunk Schlusskonferenz.